baboo jour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille jérémy père est docteur en
informatique ingénieur en r&d et alors
que j'ai tapé ton nom sur google je suis
tombé sur une page lui qui disait qui
parle de quelqu'un qui a un jardin opéra
qui fait aussi la photographie du yoga
et savait choisir cascua toi non c'est
pas moi je le nom et le nom est
relativement courant bonjour là bonjour
merci de son invitation
ben de rien ravi merci d'avoir accepté
est ce que tu vas commencer du coup par
un peu présenter ton parcours
et puis oui bien sûr donc je suis
docteur en intelligence artificielle
j'ai fait ma thèse sur le traitement du
langage naturel
j'essayais de faire comprendre aux
machines commencent structure le
dialogue c'est à dire que là par exemple
on l'on essaie de discuter on sait
exactement qui répond à quoi donc
forcément dont on est deux donc c'est
pas dur de savoir à qui on répond mais
par exemple si tu me pose une question
et que je fais un détour et que je
reprends les jeux que je fais une
véritable réponse dans cinq minutes
je sais que tu sais exactement à quoi je
fais référence
le truc c'est que une machine n'arrive
pas forcément à trouver la structure de
dialogue donc je fume ats dessus et
avant j'ai fait une école d'ingénieurs
en informatique à toulouse j'ai fait ma
thèse à toulouse est l'équipe également
et voilà c'est là et c'est la majorité
de mon parcours académique et depuis que
j'ai mon doctorat donc je les ai eues il
ya environ deux ans et demi je fais de
la recherche et développement dans une
start up toulousaine où j'essaie de
comprendre comment les gens décident et
c'est pas évident
les joueurs décident de bassins
compliqué est ce que tu peux pas un peu
plus du coût de 2 à thèse du groupe
qu'est ce que tu entends qu elle son
utilité utilisé oui alors il y a il ya
pas mal de en fait quand on essaie de de
comprendre la structure d'un texte enfin
il ya eu beaucoup de boulot sur le
monologue
c'est à dire on prend un texte
journalistique et on essaie de
comprendre comment les phrases
s'articule entre elles c'est à dire
qu'est ce qui est le développement d'une
phrase au début qu'est ce qui est une
question rhétorique et une caisse une
réponse à une question rhétorique
comment comment les choses s'enchaînent
et dans et avoir une structure déjà de
ce texte c'est relativement compliquée
et le but de ma thèse c'est est de
tenter de prendre les méthodes qui
existait donc je développe après je vais
développer après ce que c'est mais de
prendre les méthodes qui existent pour
un texte qui ajuste un auteur est
d'essayer de voir la structure qui a
quand les gens se parlent entre eux donc
d'un coup il ya plein de il ya plein de
il ya plein d'autres types de liaison
qui existent par exemple pas directement
des questions réponses des commentaires
des explications des axes knowledge man
show je sais pas comment décès en france
est d d je sais comment dix meilleurs
des rassemblements connaître oui la
reconnaissance que quelqu'un a dit
quelque chose c'est à dire tu répond pas
à la question
mais tu dis enfin j'ai bien j'ai bien
entendu ta question
donc il ya tout c'est tout c'est toutes
ces liaisons
tous et toutes ces types de relations
qui apparaissent dans les dialogues et
on a essayé de retrouver la structure à
partir de ça alors le problème c'est
qu'il ya plein plein plein de structures
possible donc on utilisait un langage de
description qui avait été créée par là
mon maître mais m mais mais maître de
thèse qui comporte dix sept 17 liaisons
possibles entre des bouts de phrases et
le rôle m c'est que bien tu prends tu
prends tous les bouts de phrases d'un
discours et tu peux avoir des milliers
des milliards de de graff possible entre
donc il va falloir ruser pour en
construire un ça fait que on a commencé
à faire un un système qui essaient de
prédire la relation entre juste deux
bouts de phrases et après d'essayer de
reconstruire le le la structure la plus
probable à partir de toutes les
prédictions entre des pères deux bouts
de phrases et donc on a réussi à
dépasser l'état de l'art il n'était pas
très bon au départ on a réussi à avoir
les résultats à peu près équivalent à ce
que l'on observé dans dans le monologue
et la recherche progresse toujours
dessus les pistes et les pistes
intéressantes c'est que ben on enfin ils
se rendent du compte donc c'est la suite
du la suite du projet c'est d'utiliser
des des informations qui ne sont pas
linguistique c'est à dire que si tu es
si tu lis par exemple la transcription
du la transcription du dialogue tu vas
essayer d'avoir une structure tu vas à
peu près comprendre comment ça marche il
ya des événements qui se passent autour
du dialogue
par exemple une voiture qui passe des
choses qui arrivent
entre les deux entre les de locuteurs
auquel les locuteurs vont faire
référence pendant le dialogue donc si tu
as la connaissance de ce qui se passe
autour
tu peux facilement faire une structure
donc ça c'est ça c'est la suite et là je
suis en train de raconter la lila là
toutes les limites de ce qu'on ait de ce
qu'il est encore posé de ce qu'il est
possible de faire dans le dans le
domaine donc ok encore plus belle
mannequin québécois ont le domaine qui
qui a l'air de d'évoluer très très vite
alors ça brille ça dépend ça dépend
alors ça fait ça fait depuis quelques
années alors j'aime bien faire le
comparatif avec avec le traitement
d'image donc il ya eu un hymne à jean
est donc quand il ya eu pour la première
fois le diplôme ning qui a fait son
entrée
énorme dans le dans la scène
internationale en disant waouh on a des
super performance il ya eu un peu la
même chose
il n'y a pas si madrid je dois dire il
ya deux ans je crois j'ai pas envie de
dire des bêtises mais environ où il ya
une nouvelle architecture de type
learning qui utilisent plein plein de
données qui d'un coup explosé pas mal de
mes tricks qui était assez performante
donc on disait ça y est maintenant le
traitement du langage
ça va aller dix fois plus vite parce
qu'on a trouvé des méthodes qui marche
bien mais le problème c'est que ça ça
marche bien pour certaines tâches
simples mais on s'attendait un peu à ce
que les tâches simples ça soit conduire
en traitement du langage
on sait que le problème est super
compliqué c'est assez dur de faire
comprendre le langage humain à une
machine de comprendre toutes les
subtilités de comment ça marche
donc on sait généralement concentrer sur
des tâches vraiment simple mais résoudre
cet âge vraiment simple avec un système
qui bat tout ce qu'ils avaient avant ça
veut pas dire que c'est que que c'est
résolu dont on a l'impression d'avancer
beaucoup plus vite sur la résolution des
tâches simples sur les trucs de base et
tout ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'on
rentre beaucoup avec beaucoup plus de
vitesse dans le mur de
la suite maintenant on va devoir
résoudre à les trucs compliqués on se
rend compte que la génération texte
c'est chouette mais alors maintenant on
va essayer de générer un texte cohérent
et l'asean vilain beaucoup plus dur et
voilà donc ça s'accélère dans le sens où
on a beaucoup plus d'outils et aussi
parce que ledit planning se démocratise
et du coup il ya plein de gens qui
peuvent entrer dans le domaine et
réutiliser les outils que tout le monde
utilise
il ya beaucoup plus d'intérêt dans le
domaine ya c'est super chouette
donc ça se passe et ça s'accélère dans
le sens mais on ne s'attend pas à ce que
il ya une maintenant une révolution tous
les trois jours
quand tu parlais de nouvelles
architectures c'est qu'on soit ouverte
tout à fait les transforme en jeu lancé
à elmo à berthe
donc elle mo hayder alors pour ceux qui
écoutent et les les chercheurs aime bien
me donner des petits noms au machin qui
construisent donc mettre un gros tas
d'équations dans un papier ses shopi
mais leur donner un nom ça claque tout
le monde en parle donc donc ils ont ils
ont misé en donner elmo et du coup ils
se sont dit ok elle mot personnage de
rue sésame
maintenant le suivant on va l'appeler
berthe fautes personnelles
et ça depuis il ya eu des dmm absolument
géniaux mais oui c'était celle
architecture transformer n'y a rien à
voir avec les transformers mais qui est
une architecture relativement plus
simple que celle qui avait avant c'est à
dire que quand on fait du camp quand on
fait du diplôme bing on essaie de
décrire les transformations qu'on va
qu'on va faire aux données et on va
essayer de décrire une fonction super
compliqué pour pour pour transformer les
données en quelque chose de
en une solution balle à la fonction est
techniquement moins compliqué dans cette
description
ça veut pas dire qu'elle est moins
compliquée à calculer mais en gros les
briques qu'on a utilisé la sont beaucoup
plus redondantes entre elles elles sont
moins moins tordue il ya moins de
subtilité dans tous les sens donc d'un
coup on pouvait on empile et plus et
s'est rendu compte que en enquillant
plein va ça marche et quand même on
n'avait pas besoin d'eux on n'avait pas
besoin de toutes ces de tous ces
branchements subtil on avait juste à
empiler des couches mais fallait il
fallait trouver les bonnes couche à
empiler donc ses choix qu'ils aient
trouvé ça mais à partir du moment où on
a trouvé une bonne couche est plus temps
mais plus tu en as bas ses abonnés et ça
a donné de très bons résultats
ce que tu veux toi pendant les utiliser
plus des réseaux neuraux de rupture ont
dit non même pas même pas non non non
non non les les
ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est pratique
c'est que le le le domaine je faisais ma
thèse il était tellement 1
alors je vais pas dire à la ramasse il
était un des problèmes les plus
compliqués du traitement du langage
donc on n'avait pas besoin d'avoir des
grosses architecture de diplômes ning à
la pointe pour obtenir des résultats
intéressants
le gros de mon boulot c'était pas la
partie machine learning qui essayaient
de savoir s'il ya une forte probabilité
qu'il y ait une liaison entre deux
phrases
c'était la partie comment reconstruire à
partir de ce genre de prédictions une
structure cohérente
par exemple tu peux pas remonter le
temps
tu ne peux pas répondre à une question
qui a été posée dans le futur donc ça
veut dire que quand tu construis ta
structure
tu peux pas faire des liaisons en
arrière donc ça c'est une une un truc
simple mais tu peux rajouter plein de
contraintes comme ça et dire ok suivant
ces contraintes
suivant les trucs qui disent ok ça fait
ça a du sens tu sais que tu peux pas
construire telle ou telle structure
n'importe comment
tu exprimes des contraintes et à partir
de là tu essaies de tu dis que si on
suit ces contraintes
alors la structure la plus probable
qu'il respecte ses contraintes va être
plus cohérente que si tu prends juste
toutes les liaisons qui sont les plus
probables non donc ça c'est ce qu'on
voulait prouver et c'est ce qu'on a fait
et ça c'est juste un truc on peut il est
très possible que jean relais les
doctorants qui soit arrivée les
chercheurs ou doctorants qui sont passés
après moi j'utilise du dip learning pour
dire bon maintenant qu'on a ça on va on
va attaquer le sou problème avec avec
des techniques de machine learning plus
avancées et ça fera encore mieux mais à
chaque fois c'est un cri mental
moi j'ai pas eu besoin du diplôme ning
mais ça veut pas dire que c'est pas
utile et du coût de la structure du
barça c'était phillies et le producteur
mais tant que ces graphes orienté
étiqueté ouais ouais c'est un graphe non
à cycliques et non notre part dans le
pré un grâce à cycling race donc comment
dire français un graphe grâce non à 6 6
1 grâce à cyclique avec des avec des
avec des labels dessus donc les noeuds
du graff c'est les bouts de phrases les
unités élémentaires du discours et
autres bals ya les liaisons
questions-réponses réactions
commentaires
objection au projet saison qu'à un
ensemble de phrases mais des phrases
comme ça et puis on a une flèche d'une
phrase à l'autre
c'est ça et qui dit que l'autre répond
au premier non plus il ya une étiquette
sur l'arête qui dit ce qu'elle pense
exactement cse
c'est ce genre de graff qu'on dirige
cyclique c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
s'arrêter dans le temps parce que des
fois tu peux alors il ya une acception
as tu peux pas remonter dans le temps
c'est quand tu
quand tu sais un commentaire si un truc
que tu vas dire c'est par exemple
faites attention ce que je vais dire est
très compliqué mais bla bla bla bla bla
du coup là c'est un commentaire qui part
dans le truc que tu dis après vers le
vert le vert le disclaimer que tu as mis
en avant mais tu peux quand même pas
avoir de cycle tu ne peux pas je ne peux
quand même pas avoir de situer c'est
parce que la la ça casse la causalité
c'est en gros dans la définition des
étiquettes
il y en a qui disent ça sert à rien
d'avoir tu peux utiliser cette étiquette
uniquement si tu acceptes les trucs en
arrière sinon on est obligé d'avoir deux
étiquettes différentes si tu forces
toutes les arêtes à aller en avant mais
même ce truc mais tu ne dois jamais
absolument avoir de 6 à 106
sémantiquement vous pouvez pas gérer la
phrase de de gaulle n'ont eu que d'elle
là bas la menace était tentante à dire
et il faut la ben on triche en fait je
te dire qu'on représente
on représente pas le contenu de la
phrase on représente les liaisons entre
entre les entre entre les trucs par
exemple tu dirais la phrase que je viens
de te dire fosses à la rigueur met même
en fait ça c'est une unité du discours
si tu vas pas commencer à le découper
mais par contre à 1 d un des trucs
intéressants c'est à coup à quoi ça sert
de faire une structure comme ça c'est
parce que on essaye à un moment de dire
voilà que contient la phrase c'est à
dire quel est le sens de la phrase par
exemple quand tu dis je mange une pomme
tu sais qu' il ya un truc qui s'appelle
pomme qui existent que moi je suis
quelque chose qui peut manger des trucs
que à un moment temporellement je me
suis retrouvé avec une paume de la main
et que je vais probablement mangé
donc il ya tout les informe tout ce que
tu comprends quand toi tu entends je
mange une pomme
ll est à l'échelle de quelques mots
d'une phrase on peut essayer de
représenter ça de façon logique on peut
dire
il existe un objet x qui est une pomme
et que qui est l'objet d'une action d'un
aignan donc il ya plein de façons de
représenter mathématiquement le sens des
phrases qui va jeudi qu'elle existe
c'est pas dire qu'ils sont bonnes ça
veut dire quoi on essaie d'extraire des
trucs mais une fois que tu as la
structure de la delà du discours ben à
partir des étiquettes que tu as mis
dessus
là chaque étiquette à une sémantique et
là une sémantique sebha du coup ça va
être une recette pour dire ben voilà les
informations contenues dans le premier
truc dans le deuxième et en fonction de
l'étiquette voilà comment on va les
combinés non mais ça c'est a trait à
très très long terme c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les dialogues sont
tellement compliquées on ne s'est pas
représenté toute l'information qui a
dans un dialogue
ils ont dit on va découper le problème
on va dire ben ok d'un côté on va dire
va prendre une phrase et dire voilà
qu'est ce qu'il ya là dedans c'est on va
prendre la deuxième on va dire qu'est ce
qu'il ya dedans est ce que des trucs
dans la première phrase sans référence à
la première
comment on va les combinés et tout ça en
le faire d'un quart d'heure on le fait
en un quart de seconde nous humains mais
la junte où on met tellement loin allez
on avance que le groupe les actions de
leur histoire de transformer peut-être
un peu ces histoires de faire des liens
entre les mots non ce qui me similarités
pas rejoué il ya une similarité au sens
statistique du terme c'est à dire que
c'est plus facile de raisonner ça en
interne en termes thématique parce que
par exemple il y a
un dé transformer les plus les plus cool
de ces derniers temps c'est jimmy choo
donc qui a été je sais même plus je suis
un moment ce que voulait dire mais bon
bref un transformers assez cool sortie
par copenhague aille qui en gros une des
utilisations un peu sympa c'est tu lui
donnes une phrase et il continue la
phrase il génère un texte à partir de la
phrase ça on peut le tester et incite
talk to transformer on peut faire simple
on peut y passer des après midis dessus
c'est rochette
mais l'idée c'est par exemple si on
commence à parler de des licornes ont
été découvertes dans la cordillère des
andes
c'est yves a commencé à sortir un texte
de oui alors une équipe de recherche
menée par le docteur perez des ide et il
va continuer donc il va garder le thème
du mot parce que le transformer arrive à
dire voilà quand on a des mots qui parle
par exemple de licorne de nature et de
cordillère des andes souvent dans la
suite du texte il ya des trucs qui parle
de cornes de parce que je suis pas de
bolivie de chercheurs quand il ya
découverte ça veut dire qu'il peut
peut-être recherche et ainsi de suite
donc statistiquement quand un
transformers lors de son entraînement
vallières des tas et des tas et des tas
et des tas de texte quelque part
représentée d'une certaine façon on ne
sait pas comment mais on sait que c'est
un peu la magie des la magie des
statistiques on le sait à peu près
comment on va s'y prendre pour europe
pour pour exprimer à la machine qu'on va
plier un mécanisme qui s'appelle le
mécanisme d' attention qui dit on va
essayer d'apprendre à la machine quelles
sont les parties quelles sont les
parties de la phrase quelles sont les
parties du texte précédent auquel il
faut faire attention pour savoir quels
mots choisir
donc ça s'entraîne très bien enfin
aujourd'hui ça s'entraîne très bien
avant c'était plus compliqué de 29 et du
coup ça fait qu'en lisant plein de
textes
le système va comprendre tout seul les
maux les plus probable dans le contexte
et le contexte c'est des trucs qui
peuvent être juste avant mais maintenant
on peut entraîner de façon à ce que ça
prenne aussi des trucs qu'il y avait
trois paragraphes avant et du coup ça
fait war comment la machine peut-elle
comprendre qu'il faut faire des liaisons
aussi long mais bah ça on va dire que ça
juste marche c'est c'est un peu s'est
pas complètement magique
aujourd'hui mais on a toujours ce
problème de voir on a entraîné un truc
avec des millions de paramètres on lui a
donné à manger des tas de texte il a
fait des liaisons mais on ne peut pas
prouver qu'il ya tel ou tel liaison à
part en essayant de de lui faire faire
ouais donc pour ceux qui n'ont jamais
entendu parler du petit hugo fait
l'histoire des licornes dans les cordes
il a besoin de ces l'exemple qui avaient
été données ou attendant sur le blog de
neige ils ont passé un article un faux
article écrit par ap à pardies picchu
qui est l'invité vivement à lire il est
assez fun et maintenant tout le monde
tout le monde peut créer des comme ça
hein
le site comme tout transformer vous
balancer une phrase ça vous fait des
textes et ses ventes à découvert ça
c'est quoi ta réaction des petits tubes
là alors la première fois qu'il a la
première fois qu'il a été sorti
oh je vais je mate je m'attendais pas
spécifiquement à ça je m'attendais à un
truc du genre ouais c'est à dire que
j'avais déjà vu par exemple les trucs
les trucs de vision les trucs de les
générateurs de les générateurs d'image
par exemple cette personne n'existe pas
mais voilà elle a été créée par un
parent un truc donc j'avais déjà mis à
jour mon curseur dans la direction de
attention les ja avec suffisamment de
d'entraînement peuvent générer des
fruits que vaguement plausible donc si
ça avait été cela était possible pour
les images à court ou moyen terme
c'était un peu inévitable on va dire que
ça soit pour le texte donc au moment où
ses sorties j'avais déjà été un peu
préparé à ce que ça arrive
obama s'est fait par contre le truc
auquel je ne m'attendais pas mais après
coup c'était c'était bon c'était un peu
évident c'est le fait que au canada ils
disent ok on a on a fait ce modèle là et
on va pas le sortir
il n'a pas pu dire ça
enfin après après avoir lu le truc je me
suis dit oui non mais c'est normal c'est
normal qu'ils c'est normal qu'ils c'est
normal qu'ils le sortent pas mais
j'étais juste surpris parce que juste je
m'y attendais pas à ce qu'il y ait eu
beaucoup de réactions assez virulente du
temps sur les réseaux sociaux
suite à ça oui plutôt c'était jeu alors
il y en a beaucoup qui disait que
c'était un coup marketing que oh là là
bas nord normalement tout le monde en
cours notamment dans les publications
moderne d'intelligence artificielle
les gens donnent le code les gens
donnent les données les gens donnent
même les modèles entraîner parce que
c'est bien parce que ça fait avancer la
recherche parce que salah reproductible
donc c'était un peu c'était un peu
contre
quand on contre contrôle et j'allais
dire la norme scientifique contre les
habitudes du domaine de rester dans son
coin c'était ce n'était pas cool mais en
fait elle la raison c'est juste que a
priori open eyes est une des missions de
pagaille c'est de faire en sorte
d'améliorer la halle en partie
d'améliorer la gouvernance de l'ia c'est
à dire on a des systèmes de plus en plus
puissants on sait pas forcément s'ils
vont avoir des effets indésirables
donc on peut pas empêcher ça chez les
autres si on n'a pas d'abord montré que
faire ça se poser les questions de
l'utilisation malicieuse de l'ia faire
attention aux conséquences de des
systèmes qu'on va on va rendre public
six personnes se posent la question il
ya personne a aucune raison que que les
gens le fassent donc il se disait
peut-être que peut-être que le truc
qu'on rend public va avoir des va avoir
des conséquences néfastes
donc on va dire on va attendre dans six
mois peut-être que on va le publier et
d'ailleurs c'est un peu ce qu'ils ont
fait un là encore il ya deux trois
semaines ils ont publié la version quasi
quasi quasi complète de leurs modèles
mais l'objectif était patente de 2,2 je
pensais que c'était moins de dire
attention ce système en particulier va
faire de gros dégâts
c'est de signaler à tout le monde que
prendre le temps que se poser les
questions
c'est une bonne chose parce que parce
qu'il ya eu des débats virulents mais il
ya aussi pleine discussion sur
est ce que c'est bien de faire ça est ce
que c'est normal est-ce que vous avez
vous raison à ce que voit et ça ça
c'était bon ça c'est ouais
car ce cap au nord est du coup des gens
qui bossent pas pas sur les aspects
diamé plus forte gouvernance et risque
est en effet le zouk clairement et
beaucoup de réflexion en interne sur les
suivre sur tous ces sujets et je trouve
ça vraiment intéressant ce que tu dis en
effet le fait de nous non pas que ce
soit si mal de rendre ce code en
particulier open c'est difficile parce
que c'était difficile à prévoir les
effets secondaires ma prison mais ils
ont peut-être catastrophique non plus
mais bon ça c'est un générateur de
textes les les trucs qui sortent si pas
courir mais c'est engage une discussion
sur
finalement est-ce que les normes qu'on a
dans la manière de faire la recherche
sont un ne pose pas des risques je pense
exactement et donc tout ça ça nous amène
aussi du coût de ce soit envers des
problématiques un peu plus d'altruisme
efficace un peu ce que tu coûtes hutues
membre de la très efficace
je suis membre de l'association
altruisme efficace france avant d'y être
jeté dans le mouvement altruisme
efficace en général dont dont
l'association et d'un des membres dont
40 a fini dans ce bordel au cours
foucault
oh ça a été ça a été c'était tortueux là
alors je vais je vais y aller depuis
depuis en arrière alors je j'ai commencé
à être familier avec les principes de
l'altruisme efficace par un autre site
qui s'appelle les vang mon mac c'est
anglet absolument horrible donc par une
commune par une communauté qui alors en
français ça s'appelle i laquelle la
communauté rationaliste le truc c'est
que en français rationaliste ça une
connotation extrêmement différente de de
sel ça c'est la raison c'est ça peut
très vite dégénérer en la raison au
dessus de tout
en mode en mode ultra cartésien et où
donc
donc en gros une communauté qui était
qui réfléchit beaucoup aux biais
cognitif la recherche de la vérité ça
ressemble un peu à la la communauté pack
tapas sceptique mais d'esprit critique
et et mais aussi avec une dimension
assez importants sur essayer de prendre
de bonnes habitudes essayer d'augmenter
sa productivité essayer de trouver les
bugs dans son propre comportement de
trouver les bugs dans c'est dans l'est
dans sa façon de penser comment
atteindre ces objectifs
donc il ya plein plein plein plein plein
de plein de plein de trucs dedans et une
des raisons pour lesquelles cette
communauté avait été fondée c'était
parce que il y avait un type et les
élites comme ski qui s'est dit alors
voila moi mon gros problème c'est je
veux que les gens soient capables de
raisonner sur des intelligences
artificielles super super super évolué
on a probablement parlé après mais je
considère ce problème comme très
important mais il a un gros problème
c'est que on ne peut pas raisonner ray
dessus calmement en général c'est à dire
il ya trop de ya trop de pièges de
réponses toutes faites qui sont balancés
par plein de gens qui entend parler du
problème pour la première fois et j'ai
pas envie juste pas envie donc il a
commencé à parler de biais cognitif il a
commencé à parler de 2 comment mieux
débattre aussi de comment de comment
mettre à jour s'est laissé ses trucs et
afin de pouvoir discuter calmement de
2,10 à avancer de super intelligence et
au milieu
dans cette communauté il ya des gens qui
se sont dit attendez mais
tous ces outils là tous ces outils là
pour atteindre ses objectifs pour
raisonner correctement sur les trucs il
se trouve qu'il y avait une autre
communauté qui commençait à n'être donc
plutôt du côté d'oxford donc une cause
qui était plutôt du côté californie une
autre communauté qui commençait à naître
qui était la communauté altruisme
efficace qui l essayer de résoudre les
problèmes du monde et essayer de trouver
les meilleures opportunités pour pour
les résoudre
donc c'est un peu naturellement que les
deux communautés ont commencé à se se
polliniser entraîne donc y en a plein
qui il ya eu il ya eu un petit ami que
dès qu'il ya eu beaucoup de croisement
qui se sont fait les deux et donc et des
gens qui est du coupage et c'est là où
mon histoire arrive c'est que moi j'ai
commencé par la communauté dans le
strass yona liste parce que parce que je
lisais je suis tombé non pas tout à fait
par hasard mais je suis tombé sur une
fan fiq de harry potter
écrite par ioukos qui harry potter et
les méthodes de la rationalité qui a été
traduite en français et que je
recommande qui en gros c'est harry est
un rationaliste et il présente des
concepts qui m'ont juste plus je me suis
dit ouais c'est chouette de réfléchir
comme ça je suis tombé sur la communauté
rationaliste puis je suis tombé sur
l'altruisme efficace et puis je finis
par m'orienter parme orienté jeu que je
suis je fais toujours partie de la
communauté ratio nice mais c'est comme
ça que suis tombé dedans et c'est du
coup tout a commencé vers quelques
années parce que maintenant je suis
[Musique]
alors les ongs j'ai découvert ça en 2014
je dirais
l'altruisme efficace à peu près la même
année après avoir lu tout ce qui était
tout ce qui était possible dessus et
j'ai un j'ai rejoint altruisme efficace
france donc je commençais à un peu plus
m'investir dans le comité en france
c'était 2018
non en 2017 2010cette parce que j'en
avais gens m'avaient marque à toulouse
il n'y ait pas de demies top il n'y
avait pas de groupes nationalistes donc
je voulais en créer un
et puis je suis dans le bêta sur le
groupe altruisme efficace qui quasiment
venait d'être créée merci dit pas autant
le rejoindrai de fil en aiguille je fais
c'est pourquoi à toulouse
non on est suivant commun en compte on
est soit 2 soit 3 bon on va dire on va
dire 3 pour l'instant alors ça c'est les
membres actifs qui organise les mets qui
organise les meet up mais bon ben on
fait partie de l'assaut qui elle compte
quelques dizaines de quelques dizaines
de membres actifs je dirais il y en a
beaucoup à paris donc est un peu un peu
partout en province et on abat quelques
dizaines de gens intéressés qui viennent
à nos réunions
donc on fait ça deux fois par mois le
groupe parisien et et un est un peu plus
actif mais voilà on a on a plus de gens
que l'année dernière et l'année dernière
on avait plus de gens qu'ils avaient les
reins donc s'accroît doucement je vous
le fais quoi qu'on en dise aux deux
concepts merveilleuses bas la moitié la
moitié des mythes up sound mitterrrand
introductif
c'est à dire que les gens et que le
concept d'altruisme efficace 4 est connu
donc on fait de me taper introductif où
on fait le speech standard sur qu'est ce
que c'est qu'est ce qu'on est
qu'est ce qu'on sait quel problème on
essaie de résoudre comment on réfléchit
aux problèmes qu on veut résoudre
et après on discute sur des sujets plus
spécifiques du genre l'incertitude
morale c'est à dire que par exemple je
suis à peu près sûr que ce problème est
important mais pas tout à fait donc
est-ce que je m'y engage ce que je m'y
engage pas est ce que on sait pas trop
combien de gens sont affectés par disons
telle ou telle maladie
mais même l'incertitude morale c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus profond c'est à dire
c'est qui qui sont des agents moraux
c'est à dire est-ce que je vais est ce
que je vais dire que les animaux sont
importants est ce que les humains dans
le futur sont importants quelle place je
leur accorde et si je suis pas sûr de ma
réponse ben quelle influence ça sur mes
décisions
donc ce donc ça c'est un concept et le
truc c'est qu'il y en a plein d'autres
il ya par exemple quelles sont les
grandes causes sur lesquels on peut un
peu quelles sont les grandes causes sur
lesquels on peut agir
il y en a plein donc on peut faire des
tables dessus donc voilà le truc c'est
que à chaque fois qu'on donc qu'on nous
pose une question comme il ya peu une
question à poser ben ça donne des
occasions de faire des métopes dessus
donc un puits sans fonds c'est c'est un
puits c'est un puits sans fond
heureusement en général la communauté
altruisme efficace et juste un plein à
craquer de gens qui n'ont pas peur de se
poser des questions sans fin et 9 juste
de se prendre la tête productivement
mais se prendre la tête quand même
est-ce que des paquets ce que sont les
concepts autour du rail du rationalisme
et la très efficace qui ont le plus
marqués plus
il y en a il y en a un qui marin qui m'a
beaucoup marqué c'étaient les distances
inférentielle c'est à dire que j'aime
enfin j'aime beaucoup dans ma vie
explique et des trucs mais je ne suis
pas rendu compte
souvent avant d'avoir lu du des articles
dessus que les pré requis nécessaires
pour comprendre une explication varie
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'un auditeur
à l'autre c'est à dire que il y a il y a
une c'est pas parceque genre quelqu'un
est beaucoup plus âgés qu'eux il va
immédiatement comprendre au mieux des
explications compliqué que un gamin de
10 ans c'est pas forcément une histoire
de réfléchir mieux est d'avoir
l'expérience de ces vraiment il ya
quelqu'un qui peut être extrêmement
rapide pour comprendre des comprendre
des choses
faut quand même qu'ils passent par un
long chemin avant de comprendre un truc
qui est vraiment surprenant c'est même
pas une question de de convaincre parce
qu'il a une opinion complètement
opposées c'est un truc c'est que quand
on parle de 2
quand on a quelqu'un en face qui n'a pas
les connaissances de base c'est très
facile d'expliquer un truc est un truc
complexe en allant directement dans
l'explication du explication du concept
et que l'auditeur brûlent des étapes
c'est à dire grâce à se faire des idées
extrêmement rapide sur la question des
intuitions qui sont fausses ouais donc
il ya une distance qu'il faut respecter
et donc il faut des explications plus
longue et mesurait et j'avais tendance à
négliger cette distance c'est à dire de
toute façon si mon explication est clair
la personne en face va la con
non en fait c'est à dire il ya des
explications extrêmement clair qui sont
incompréhensibles pas parce qu'elles
sont pas claires mais parce qu'elle
demande des pré requis et parce qu'elle
demande parfois que l'auditeur découvre
par lui-même se fasse la réflexion sur
sur le sujet avant de dire bon ben
maintenant on va introduire l'auditeur à
2 y ait un deuxième concept il faut
klein pour quelqu'un qui est
suffisamment éloignée
il faut prendre du temps il faut prendre
des étapes
il faut que jamais de brûler les étapes
c est pour faire heureusement il ya
plusieurs des étapes intermédiaires mais
chaque pas est en fait potentiellement
un problème c est qu il faut bien
vérifier que la personne en face face
chacun silva parce que s'y fait pas un
peu sale autre clause est
potentiellement dérivés et il ya un
terme qui il ya un truc qui s'appelle la
des confusions
donc il ya le machine intelligence
research institute un des uns des
nombreux organismes qui bossent sur
l'intelligence artificielle qui dit une
de nos missions celle à des confusions
c'est à dire ma on a des problèmes super
compliqué et on va faire tout pour que
déjà on explique les trucs de façon
claire pour que les gens ne ne sortent
pas des bêtises accidentellement un un
des pires dangers c'est de se dire c'est
bon j'ai compris le truc alors qu'en
fait on a brûlé les étapes est qu on
perde du temps à sortir de n'importe
quoi alors que l'on reparte en des bases
on arrive à voir des dangers que je que
je crains un petit peu devant parme
livre cccc de quoi que les gens pour des
mauvaises raisons et que les gens sont
convaincus mais pour de mauvaises
raisons
et du coup vont défendre ensuite la
thèse avec des mauvais argument s'est
s'allié ensuite ça sera très
contre-productif en fait
alors avant après ils peuvent être
convaincus pour de très bonnes raisons
mais comme ils sont allés trop vite en
défense ils peuvent défendre les trucs
de façon de façon expliquer le concept
de façon tellement dans calais avec des
trous que eux n'arriveront à combien de
personnes des cetc
c'est difficile non seulement a expliqué
au jour quelque chose qui est difficile
à expliquer mais en plus les coûts les
années à faire attention alors ce qui
pourrait expliquer cette chose à faire
preuve de la même attention que c'est
assez
c'est ça et même là j'ai way j'allais
dire la même j'ai pas l'impression de 2
je suis à peu près sûr qu'on va parler
de concept compliqué dans je ne sais pas
donc dans pas très longtemps et je vais
juste faire très très attention à ce que
je vais dire en disant à ce que s est ce
que j'y vais dans le bon sens c'est ce
que nous notamment parce que certains
des concepts qui me tiennent à coeur
sont extrêmement importants pour enfin
pour moi mais ils sont importants pour
moi parce que j'estime qu'ils sont
importants pour par exemple le futur de
l'humanité aux arts jette le pavé dans
la mare quelque chose alors je vais mais
j'avais mentionné le le sujet pour
lequel tu bosses qui avait fait tous et
toutes ces explications et c'est le
problème de l'alignement
c'est alors le problème de l immense et
alors repartir de la base c'est un
problème d'intelligence artificielle
l'idée c'est qu'on veut en intelligence
artificielle
en général on va faire résoudre des
problèmes et des machines
des problèmes qui sont plus ou moins
face et par des humains mais il n'y a
pas de raison de s'attaquer à des
problèmes que les humains eux mêmes ne
peuvent pas faire en général on veut
faire résoudre des problèmes à des
machines hockey et on va construire des
méthodes pour soi dire à la machine
exactement ce qu'il faut faire pour
résoudre le problème
ou bien si on connaît pas déjà la
solution exact on va donner à la machine
un espace de recherche c'est à dire on
pense que la solution ressemble à peu
près à sac
mais il nous manque des par m par
exemple pour faire un gâteau au yaourt
je sais que je vais avoir très le tell
tale tels ingrédients mais alors j'ai
oublié les quantités et où par exemple
si tu joue aux échecs
tu sais que tu vas devoir respecter les
règles et que si tu veux gagner fois les
dans ce genre de trucs il ya tellement
de possibilités que tu peux pas juste
dire à la machine ou quoi faire donc tu
vas dire ok je définis un espace de
recherche est une méthode pour que la
machine high dans cet espace et trouve
la méthode
alors là où ça devient un peu un peu un
peu un peu dangereux c'est si dans cet
espace de recherche
il ya des méthodes que tu ne veux
absolument pas que la machine utilise
c'est à dire si c'est un jeu d'échec
c'est pas grave tu te dis que tant que
la machinerie les règles il n'y a pas de
problème mais par exemple si tu es en
train de de coder l'intelligence d'une
dune d'une voiture autonome leucate suis
dit voilà va falloir que tu ta le
contrôle de l'accélérateur et du volant
pour aller d'un point a à un point b
si tu donnes juste que ça à la voiture
autonome bah tu vas avoir des excès de
vitesse
tu vas juste avoir des piétons qui vont
se faire écraser tu vas avoir des trucs
donc
naïvement tutu code un objectif dans une
machine sans toutes les contraintes sans
spécifier exactement tout ce que tu veux
pas que la machine face si si le machin
qui essaie de trouver l'objectif si
l'optimiseur cherche des solutions les
solutions les plus simples sont pas
forcément les solutions qui respectent
les règles dans le cas général c'est pas
ça donc il faut impérativement que la
machine soit aligné avec les intentions
de l'humain c'est à dire pas juste
qu'elle résolve le problème que l'humain
dit parce que l'humain va pas forcément
pensé à spécifier tous les trucs que la
machine ne veux pas qu'elle fasse parce
que si par exemple je te dis ben va va
d'appoint un point b ben tu vas le faire
d'une façon raisonnable
la cie jeudi à une machine de me faire
un café je veux qu'elle fasse de façon
raisonnable mais j'ai pas envie de
spécifier à chaque fois fait le mais
sans écraser tout le monde se répandent
le café par tous voilà donc le problème
c'est que alors un c'est compliqué de
penser à tout 2 c'est dangereux il ya
des problèmes subtil du genre c'est
dangereux de faire une machine et de
l'empêcher de lui dire modifie pas ton
code pour retirer les pour retirer les
contraintes que tu as parce que tu
estimes que ce sera plus rapide
c'est fourbe mais mais mais c'est le
genre de truc que tu ne veux pas que la
machine face il faut penser en plus à le
mettre dedans et le pourquoi ce problème
est important parce que si tu as une
machine très très très puissante que tu
dis c'est bon c'est chouette
elle fait des trucs elle fait des trucs
qui me semble raisonnable et tu que tu
continues à lui donner de la puissance
et des responsabilités parce que son
combat
de part et ok t'as pas envie de te
retrouver dans la situation où un des
comportements indésirables que la
machine va faire c'est de tuer des gens
ou 2 ou 2 accidentellement réduire
l'humanité années et là où ça devient un
peu donc là je passe sur le mode un peu
mais tu as c'est que dès que tu
commences à dire il est possible que la
machine commence à toucher tout le monde
et je veux dire beau nom mais c'est va
l'arrêter avant c'est pas possible c'est
c'est donc personne ne serait assez
stupide pour pour lancer une machine
dans la nature pour appuyer sur le
bouton home sur une machine qui risque
de tuer des gens c'est juste pas
possible
les humains sont pas stupides ouais mais
c'est pas une question de stupidité
c'est même avec les meilleures
intentions du monde même en étant très
même en étant quasiment certain que la
machine va faire des trucs que tu veux
si une machine est suffisamment
puissante et en particulier si une
machine est plus douée que ses
concepteurs pour chercher des solutions
possibles alors ce serait sous-estimer
l'intelligence de la machine
que de dire j'ai pensé à tout ce que la
machine pourrait faire ce serait comme
dire c'est comme si par exemple
l'objection standard c'est bah de toute
façon je peux de toute façon je peut
débrancher la machine
ce serait faire insulte à l'intelligence
de la machine de dire elle se laissera
débrancher tout comme tout comme je
disais je veux empêcher de toute façon
j'ai mon adversaire aux échecs
ben j'ai juste à lui mettre deux bas et
j'augmenterai mais j'augmenterai mes
chances de gagner ce serait faire
insulte à l'intelligence de celui qui
est en face de dire il va te laisser
faire ouais donc
donc il ya il ya une face il ya une une
manière de dire que le problème de
l'alignement est compliqué parce que
c'est un problème technique très très
compliqué et où une autre manière dans
le sens de dire que le problème de
l'aliment l'aliment est compliqué parce
qu'on pense qu'il est facile c'est une
citation du possible je vous dis un truc
genre le pire danger avec une intention
certifia s'est conclue trop vite qu'on
l'a comprise c'est ça c'est c'est c'est
en fait ouais c'est je pense que c'est
d'autant pas apprécié la manière dont on
a programmé les machines jusque là où
souvent la manière de dire de glace qui
est aussi celle du tout des instructions
à appliquer à la machine c'est le code
et puis même souvent quand on fait de
l'apprentissage mais avec un objectif
qu'on conçoit et dans un environnement
qu'on conçoit bien et qu'on fait souvent
on va donner un objectif en disant bon
voire est avec cet objectif
bah du coup la machine va faire ça et ça
rit ça et ça et du coup je vois bien se
passer quoi bien sûr wind anticipe le
fonctionnement de la machine
mais c'est parce que souvent les espaces
considère de chose qui peut se passer
dans l'environnement considère est
simple c'est toujours à tourner un truc
en laboratoire sur son ordi mais si
l'espace de recherche est très très
grands comme une voiture dans le monde
que c'est sain et en environnement
complexe plus avoir des animaux qui
passent des humains qui courent c'est ça
la machine peut être très très créative
il ya d'ailleurs une une liste sur
internet surtout les toutes les 6 ou les
solutions créatives que les que les
humains n'avaient pas prévu alors
généralement que ces bêta 1
mais l'exemple que j'aime et que j'aime
alors il ya deux exemples que j'aime
beaucoup donné c'est par exemple la la
la le simulateur de marche on simule on
simule un petit robot qui marche et le
but c'était de de le faire en le moindre
pas possible
et le truc c'est que la petit robot
s'était retourné et avancer sur ses
genoux
ouais donc en fait ils faisaient tous
les spas au début juste le temps de se
retourner et après il ya les peña peña
inverse l'arrivée en avançant sur les
genoux et elle avait un score de dengue
ou alors l'ia qui jouer à tetris si on
avait oublié de lui enlever la
possibilité de mettre le jeu en pause
du coup elle perd déjà mais du coup
super ou alors l'ia qui concevait des
circuits électroniques
on lui demandait de faire un oscillateur
donc un truc qui fait décider par
exemple une sinusoïde et il faut
certains composants et en fait là là le
l'algo avait réussi à trouver un truc
c'est qu'il n'utilisait juste passé
composants et en construisant en
construisant le design le la le circuit
proposé par la machine fait ils se sont
rendus compte que la machine avait
construit d'antenne qui amplifiaient les
ondes radio qui sont justes dans
l'espace parce que y'en a partout donc
il suffisait de les amplifier et pas son
nom et paf on a créé une onde sans avoir
rien qui oscille à l'intérieur du
circuit
donc c'est ce genre de c'est ce genre de
cesser ce genre de trucs créatifs parce
que les humains ils sont créatifs il n'y
a pas de ja et on fait juste
on est juste très très bon parfois pour
trouver des moyens un peu fun un peu un
peu de faire avec ce qu'on a
parce qu'on a plein de possibilités
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément à suivre
des règles arbitraires pour résoudre des
problèmes mais en théorie il n'y a pas
de raison pour qu'une intelligence
artificielle soit pas créative non plus
si c'est juste chercher des chercheurs
et des solutions intéressantes dans un
espace
ok on va on va trouver des solutions il
faut juste que il n'y a pas de solution
d'oran l'implémentation soit à au fait
il ya le type à côté
il a été asphyxié pour la raison sur la
créativité là j'ai regardé le
documentaire alphabet sur wii sur
netflix elle vraiment ça qui est mise en
avant et notamment pour ceux qui
connaissent pas alpha go et a joué trop
lisse il signa de 10 miles et qui a fait
des coups qui ont été jugés par les
experts du jeu de go comme étant
créatifs parce que aucun humain ne
louera jouer quoi et ça a permis ou son
vrai père me sens un peu difficile à
analyser au globe mais ça semble
vraiment avoir permis à alpha vaut de
prendre un avantage les stupéfiants il
ya les fameux coup 37 de la deuxième
partie mais mais il n'y avait pas de
créativité
enfin il n'y avait pas de ils ont pas
coder la créativité
verizon coude à izon coder un espace un
espace de recherche très grand et des
moyens extrêmement puissant de chercher
dedans et en soit c'est pour moi pour
moi que le coup et a été jugé comme
créatif c'est juste parce qu'ils les
réactions à ce cours ont été extrêmement
perplexe
c'est à dire c'est comme si tu allais
dire que les premiers impressionnistes
ont été particulièrement créatif
mais parce que les premiers tableaux
étaient quelque chose de complètement
différent de ce qui se faisait avant
mais aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un sort un
un tableau impressionniste il sera pas
considéré comme aussi créatif que les
premiers peintres qui l'ont fait c'est
juste parce qu'au début ça sortait
vraiment de l'ordinaire et que si on dit
or voilà un nouvel espace de recherche
qui évoque des émotions nouvelles mais
mais et ça passe surtout par de la
surprise l'aviron
j'ai la nette impression que l'on a
tendance à dire que quelque chose écrit
avec quelque chose et créatif
si à la fois on peut percevoir sa valeur
immédiatement c'est à dire qu'on peut
reconnaître immédiatement que c'est que
c'est que c'est bien que ça remplit
l'objectif mais d'une façon inattendue
au début parce que le coup le coût 38
créatif de alpha gosses étaient je sais
plus dans quel dans laquelle des cinq
quartiers au début les gens se disaient
mais c'est bizarre genre les
commentateurs experts les pros ouais 18
mai mais pourquoi c'était tout pourri et
en fait non et en fait non après avoir
vu les probabilités de victoire de
défago d'un coup après ce coup bas mais
la partie était quasiment en poche
entend souvent par créativité c'est
vraiment surprenant et fascinant alors
c'est ça c'est amusant parce que
jusqu'au dent donc long terme d un coût
de la partie iv qui dénie parle ici dole
il ya un coût de 10 idole un moment qui
en fait peut être jugé créatif hexacore
mal fagots pas ce qui est surprenant
pour alpha condé fascinant parce qu'il
permet parce que même si elles fagots à
explorer des milliards et des milliards
et des milliards de partie ça reste une
infime partie de toutes les parties
possible de go
donc ya pas de raison non plus que alpha
gones ne puisse pas considérer enfin des
points de vie de la machine c'est un peu
dur de dire ça mais de dire que ce coût
est inattendue alors là pour le coup
c'est cette quantité puisque le dans le
programme de alpha gaulle à identifier
les probabilités que ça peut aussi des
ajouts tels ou tels coûts et un sur dix
minutes c'est extrêmement improbable et
puis d'ailleurs je sais ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'il ya aussi dans le
coup 37 le fameux coup 37 d'alpha go
vous pouvez demander alpes ago qui était
la probabilité qu'un parce qu il yal
fargo du coup avec des banques de
données de joueurs augmente à bangkok
et du coup on peut lui demander qui a
été après été qu'un humain joue ce coup
37 et puis il avait répondu le choix
d'un truc genre de condor sur 10000 un
coup surprenant c'est ça c'est cool
c'est d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs assez
fun parce que c'est généralement par les
trucs surprenant qu'on se met à jour le
plus bon c'est un coup dur c'est encore
un coup de baïse mais c'est généralement
les événements qui sont les plus
extraordinaires ben justement ça va dans
l'autre sens parce que tu as une
affirmation extraordinaire demande une
preuve eric soir bien mais tu peux leur
tournée aussi c'est une une preuve
extraordinaires sont les sons les trucs
qui vont entraîner les affirmations les
plus extraordinaires parce que tu as
appris plein de trucs
ouais parce que parce que ça n'était pas
censé arriver ça veut dire que mon
modèle interne et fo a été vraiment
fawcett et du coup c'est laisser
vraiment l'opportunité et du coup les
trucs extraordinaires il ya bien
quelqu'un qui a dû quelqu'un ou quelque
chose du coup qui a dû les explorer
parce que c'est en faisant possiblement
des trucs improbables qu'on arrive à se
dire hein je pensais pas que ça allait
marcher
ouais c'est clair et c'est un truc
laisser d'encourager là c'est pas
attention à la surprise qu est-ce que
d'intérêts la surprise c'est
l'apprentissage
s'est ralliée ouais alors du coup la
ligne mantes donc c'était pas facile
mais c'est vraiment un problème
fondamental pour futur de l'humanité
c'est si seulement c'est un des
problèmes fondamentaux
enfin aux fondamentaux non je vais je
vais pas utiliser fondamental c'est à
dire dans l'altruisme efficace il ya une
partie des problèmes qu'on appelle lé
risque existentiel s'est scellée en gros
les possibles futurs qui font que
l'humanité disparaît ou alors se
retrouve dans un cul de sac
disons non mais c'est plus facile de
c'est plus facile de réfléchir à juste
l'humanité disparaît ils ont une place
assez spécial parce que alors c'est
extrêmement brut de poser le problème en
ces termes mais en gros c'est plus
facile de se remettre de l'élimination
de 50%
non c'est plus facile de se remettre de
l'élimination de 90% de la population
terrestre que de se remettre de 100%
parce que dans entre les deux cas d'aia
entrent par exemple en 0 et 90 % il ya
six milliards de morts
et il reste un milliard de personnes qui
peuvent à la rigueur peut être
difficilement mais quand même peut-être
reconstruire une civilisation
donc ça ce serait un risque
catastrophique et le risque existentiel
où si tout le monde est mort
c'est fini c'est juste fini donc il ya
il ya une idée qu'il ya une une
une distinction qui est faite dans le
sens où si tout le monde meurt
littéralement balle à terre continuera
de tourner un généralement c'est le
problème c'est pas la terre la planète
si on est très bien sorti l'écosystème
va pas forcément apprécié beaucoup et
généralement s'il ya un truc qui élimine
l'entièreté des humains ça probablement
un truc qui n'aiment qui se fiche
complètement des animaux aussi donc
c'est un peu c'est un peu kif kif mais
dans l'absolu si on donne de la valeur
aux yeux aux vies humaines futur aux
générations futures même dans un deux ou
trois siècles
et ben si tout le monde disparaît
aujourd'hui ou dans le siècle prochain
ben il y aura pas du moins non plus dans
les millénaires prochain il y aura et
leur nombre peut être absolument énorme
il y en aura des milliards et des
milliards et des milliards et des
milliards
même si la population humaine se
stabilise donc le truc c'est que les
problèmes de l'intelligence artificielle
de l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
risque existentiel
c'est de dire ben voilà on a un à cette
technologie
on a besoin d'eux on a l'intelligence
artificielle qui est de plus en plus
puissantes et et on a trouvé on trouve
que ça peut mal tourner et on va dire à
quel point ça peut mal tourner c est là
qu est ce que ça peut mal tourner et du
genre il ya des voitures autonomes qui
se prennent un mur et il ya des gens qui
meurent ou est-ce que ça peut mal mal
tourner dans le sens on va
accidentellement anéantir l'humanité
donc ya pas il n'y a pas beaucoup de il
n'y a pas beaucoup de problèmes qui
peuvent avoir cette ampleur
l'intelligence artificielle à ce genre
d'ampleur à cause de certaines à cause
de certaines propriétés qui font que les
organismes intelligent dans dans le sens
où nous humains
le fait qu'on soit intelligent nous a
permis de faire vraiment vraiment
vraiment beaucoup de trucs donc on se
dit que c'est une machine est
intelligente elle va elle aussi pouvoir
faire beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
trucs probablement d'une façon
différente mais elle peut avoir un
impact énorme et il est possible que par
exemple si les humains n'avaient j'avais
été là que ce soit je sais pas moi les
pieuvres qu'ils aient pu être de plus en
plus intelligentes et peut-être que au
bout de quelques millions d'années que
les coeurs et finit par conquérir le
monde grâce est vrai alors il se trouve
que c'est les humains qui sont arrivés
en premier parce que les humains avec
leurs cerveaux et leurs outils et leurs
machin arriva genre aller sur la lune et
les pieuvres peuvent pas ce genre d'un
pacs et on se dit une machine
intelligente par le fait qu'elle est
intelligente et qu'elle peut résoudre
des problèmes vaguement arbitraire peut
avoir un impact colossal
ça c'est le raisonnement qui dit ok on
va mettre intelligence artificielle dans
la case technologie qui comporte un
risque existentiel il y en a d'autres du
genre la guerre nucléaire du genre
l'ingénierie biologique
c'est à dire en bon encore une fois par
accident généralement ces deux accidents
que ont créé un virus qui décime voire
anéanti l'humanité mais c'est des trucs
qui qui sont et qui sont et qui qui sont
dangereux ou mais pas dans le sens
l'apocalypse est pour bientôt
sait on
il ya des gens dans la communauté
altruisme efficace qui se pose la
question mais pas parce que il pense que
ça va arriver
certainement dans le siècle à venir
juste que ça peut arriver et que une
faible probabilité d'un truc très très
très très
très mauvais même s'il ya juste 1% que
l'humanité cette année c'est pas un truc
c'est pas un truc on veut que ce soit à
0 0 0 0 1% de chance c'est un truc on
veut que ça soit un truc déjà qu'on veut
voir venir qu'on veut pouvoir réagir on
veut que il faudrait vraiment qu'on ait
pas de bol pour que ça arrive
ouais c c est pour ça que je pense que
ce qui ce qui peut être difficile c'est
de faire la différence entre 1% et
sérieux 0 1% peut-être vous vision vers
10 000 1 pour cent
assez assez assez durs pour c'est assez
dur pour de de manipuler ce genre de
trucs comment comment comme par exemple
c'est là que les biais cognitifs entre
entre un peu en jeu par exemple je crois
que c'est en 2018
il n'y a pas eu un seul crash d'avion
commercial il va pas 1 0 n'est pas un
mort et et il ya eu des dizaines et de
dizaines et des dizaines de milliers d'
accidents de la route avec des morts
mais
un avion un avion est beaucoup plus sûr
qu'une voiture vraiment quel que soit le
quel que soit le quelle que soit la
métrique genre même en disant par
kilomètre par passager par whatever
c'est juste plus sûres mais mais la
viande ça fait peur plus que plus plus
que plus que la voiture nous ou même si
on prend juste que la voiture on va
sous-estimé la probabilité d'un accident
sur un trajet comprend tous les jours
que prendre une autoroute qu'on ne
connaît pas de nuit etc et c'est très
dur de faire la différence entre faible
probabilité est encore plus faible
probabilité parce que c'est très facile
déjà d'une c'est très facile de de dire
ses proches de zéro donc c'est zéro
alors que de façon relative il ya
certains risques qui vont arriver dix ou
cent fois plus que d'autres et soit ils
vont nous à part tous pareils soient
tous nuls soit et on a du mal à comparer
en général soit les très petit nombre
soit les très grand nombre et le le le
conseille généralement qui est donné
c'est tétouan et multiplie ses sites à 6
si on a si on a un moyen de quantifier
avec des stats avec des machins vaut
mieux avoir une vague idée qui est issu
de la multiplication de plein de
composantes que d'avoir une vague idée
tout seul une estimation faite avec des
chiffres en essayant de décomposer le
problème c'est comme une estimation de
fermi je passe
est ce que tu en as permet déjà dans une
autre vidéo pareillement de définir
alors une estimation de fermi c'est par
exemple le dire
combien il ya des éléphants surnom par
combien et combien d'autres avions elle
combien est vol d'avion ou combien de
gens sont en train de rouler sont en ce
moment en train de rouler en voiture à
ceux à cet instant précis regarde autant
une voiture voilà dans une voiture qui
roule en train de rouler la main
combien réalisons kara vous mettez pause
gérard et fixez vous donner une réponse
et vous essayez pas de faire des calculs
hein c'est juste bam à un chiffre bas
puis avait pas sur wikipédia ou contre
quoi de toute façon et molly parker
toute facilité sur wikipédia n'y a pas
ce genre de truc par contre ce que vous
pouvez trouver sur wikipédia c'est
combien de voitures qui sont genre
vendus chaque année ou combien de
voitures qui sont immatriculés chaque
année pouvez-vous dire ok quel quel est
le jeu en quelle est la proportion de
temps quelle est la proportion de
conducteurs de conducteurs dans que en
france ou en suisse où n'importe où
parmi cette proportion
combien vont combien vont devoir se
déplacer tous les jours parmi sa qu'elle
est à peu près en moyenne et pour faire
ce genre de situation vous allez juste
pensé aux gens autour de vous saad vous
donner une estimation tout pourri vous
n'allez pas avoir le chiffre exact mais
quand vous avez vous dire ok en fonction
de ça je vais faire une grosse
multiplication à la fin le chiffre
auquel vous vous arriverez à la fin sera
plus proche
quasiment certainement plus proche de la
vérité que le premier chiffre auquel
vous vous vous aurais imaginé au début
parce que même si les estimations sont
toutes pourries et enrico fermi donc le
il était coriace qu'il était
mathématicien son fils disposition
physicien
bref du beau et il disait même si même
si vous ratez d'un de 10 fois ou deux
cents fois vos héros au moins une chance
de se contrebalancer et du coup vous
allez arriver à une estimation qui est
plus proche de la vérité avec juste
tenté juste parce que vous avez essayé
de décomposer le problème après ferme il
est en décadence morale en séries alors
ses quatre petits fermiers est-il du
tri-nations notre nation allez on live
alors au alors avant d'avoir fait le
calcul
j'aurais dit il ya à les cent mille
personnes avant d'avoir fait le avoir
d'abord fait le calcul
donc là normalement c'est là où je
commence à sortir vos expédia a donc ok
je vais je vais y aller sans s'en sent
en essayant à la louche on va dire que
y'a soissons à la louche 65 millions de
personnes en france
donc on va dire en france aujourd'hui en
france combien il y en a
65 millions de personnes parmi on va
dire que la la
à la louche une moitié sont le permis
j'arrondis le but c'est de faire des
arrondis de toute façon parce que les
amandiers ensemble on s'en fiche à faire
donc on va dire 30 millions de personnes
qui ont le permis
parmi ces 30 millions de personnes qui
ont le permis on va dire que a les deux
en arrondissant deux tiers prennent deux
tiers prennent à la moitié prennent leur
voiture tous les jours on arrive à 15
millions on va dire que les gens qui
roulent font une demi heure une demi
heure une heure de trajet par jour en
moyenne
donc c'est une autre histoire
au hasard dans la journée elle c'est à
dire que toute personne qui a son permis
et qui roulent fréquemment
donc on va dire les 15 millions la prend
en moyenne roule en moyenne 30 minutes
par jour
parce que là il est 7h30 du coup ce
moment je suis là maintenant ok asus oui
abstrait ouais ouais alors s'il est
maintenant si cette heure et demie ça
veut dire que on va dire que
[Musique]
ouais bon alors on va dire que du coup
parmi les 15 millions qui me semble trop
et que parmi les 10 15 millions clients
ouais parce que si je les fais ça
j'aurais dit quels sont les quels sont
les quelles sont les causes pour
lesquelles les gens prennent leur
voiture donc on va dire que les gens
rentrent du goût ok ok attends attends
on va on va le faire relativement
correctement
on va dire que ceux qui sont sur la
route c'est en majorité les gens qui
rentrent du boulot on va dire que parmi
les 15 millions qui prennent truc
récemment me dire il ya 10 millions qui
vont rentrer du boulot entre va dire
17h30 et 20h30
parme on va dire que en moyenne rentrer
du boulot ça prend une demi heure donc
vu qu'on a pris un créneau de trois
heures ça veut dire qu'à n'importe quel
moment il ya un sixième des personnes de
l'échantillon de la cuisson qui sont sur
la route aujourd'hui est en feu et en
faisant la multiplication ça va nous
donner
disons 12 millions soit un 6e essai à
faire 2 millions voilà ça veut dire que
la monf estimations là c'est deux
millions de personnes qui en ce moment
là il est 19 heures 39 ha sont sur la
route en france et je suis à peu près
sûr que je suis plus proche de la vérité
que mes 100 milles du début je serais
pas surpris si c'était plus proche d'un
million ça me semble quand même beaucoup
et ça me semble quand même beaucoup 2
millions là sur 2 millions là en ce
moment sur la route ça fait beaucoup de
monde sur la route
petit bonus là quel est ton l'écart type
d'incertitude boad à 90% l'intervalle à
90% qu'il y aurait je dirais intervalles
à 90% entre un ouais c'est beaucoup
interval 90% entre 500 milles entre 500
1000 et et on va dire 2 millions
pas plus ok tu vois la basse mais les
idées reçues la jardinerie 508 moi
j'aurais dit ça peut pas être 500 1000
et 3,4 millions voilà voilà voilà donc
si et des auditeurs qui veulent des
infos plus solide mais justement un truc
c'est que là on est en audio là on est
en live mais le principe c'est que si
jamais il ya des auteurs qui disent ah
c'est pas bon c'est pas bon le truc
c'est de se dire c'est pas bon parce que
je sais que les parce que vont se dire
voilà on va trouver les nombres là dans
mon estimation de la quantité à l'epa
bonne blablabla mais le truc c'est que
si vous dites heures vous arrivez à une
estimation une estimation que vous avez
fait avec cette méthode en corrigeant
mois mais chiffre bas vous arriverez une
estimation mais de base si on vous avait
posé la question vous vous auriez sortie
peut-être un lac en laye vous a demandé
de mettre pause
vous avez sorti un chiffre là maintenant
quand je donnais le fric et vous vous
dites ah non c'est faux parce que par m
vous allez sortir un autre chiffre
et celui-là sera plus proche de ce que
vous avez pensé au départ sera plus
proches veulent bien il sera plus proche
que vous le chiffre de vote mois passés
à ces jeux leschi saisi consommation à
chaque fois en tête c et puis juste
s'entraîner tu pourras faire c'est un
peu c'est ici c'est petit estimations
mieux sentir la passe et surtout que
l'intuition est vraiment pas fiable ces
questions mais c'est un après la la la
on s'amuse avec des chiffres ce qui est
qui et ce qui est assez chouette c'est
que le truc de essayer de décomposer le
problème essayer d'y réfléchir et c'est
moche hein c'est pas que pour les
estimations c'est aussi pour les plans
c'est aussi pour essayer de résoudre un
problème que vous avez dans la vie c'est
la comète ça c'est pas c'est pas de
trouver une manière par exemple de vous
motiver un truc que vous arrivez à faire
c'est aussi une histoire de
planification
s'est décomposé le problème qu'est ce
qu'il faut absolument que vous fassiez
pour faire un problème de commencer à
des composés de commencer à y réfléchir
un des trucs qui a dans la communauté
rationaliste c'est asseyez-vous cinq
minutes et prenez cinq minutes pour
vraiment essayer de résoudre le problème
c'est vraiment pas de dire comment vous
allez résoudre leurs problèmes pas de
vous jeter tête baissée dans machin
c'est de dire faites un plan prenez cinq
minutes et s'y est vraiment de faire un
blog comme si c'était comme si c'était
quelqu'un de complètement paniqué comme
si c'était complètement de complètement
qui était pas en état de réfléchir au
machin et que vous essayez de l'aider un
maximum est de dire voilà comment tu vas
faire suivre ce truc et vous prenez 5000
pour réfléchir à un problème est juste
mais de mettre en route la machine et et
c'est et j'allais dire c'est un peu
jailliront même dans l'altruisme
efficace ya beaucoup de problèmes comme
ça c'est essayons de mettre notre notre
comédien notre réaction à chaud de côté
ouais et de dire voilà on va y réfléchir
calmement annoncer sur ces 41 00
c'est un peu un truc de l'informaticien
casser un peu de donner la réponse c'est
d'écrire l'algorithme ça c'est on va on
va les composés le problème va voyez
également et et calmement ça veut pas
dire de de balancer les émotions dehors
c'est un truc c'est je vais mentionné un
peu un peu avant que qu'on parle de
rationalisme en français on a tendance à
dire la raison pure et la raison pure et
la clé des solutions et qu'il faut se
détacher des problèmes mais mais mais
mais en fait
mais en fait non parce que même si même
si par exemple si vous voulez si vous
voulez dire voilà je voudrais préparer
une omelette n'ont peut-être pas une
omelette genre 10 ont préparé un plat
compliqué où il ya des légumes à rouhia
des légumes à faire cuire mais il faut
découper le genre faire cuire des faire
cuire des oignons genre vous pouvez
faire des vous pouvez faire des plans il
ya plein de plans qui sont valides et en
utilisant la raison pure vous allez
peut-être trouvé le plan qui est
d'acheter des oignons les émincer des
trucs mais si vous aimez vraiment pas
découper les oignons
là il ya aussi genre d oignon
prédécoupés surgelés c'est un plan que
la raison pure elle aussi va va
découvrir parce qu'il ya plein de
possibilités et a pas de raison que vous
pouviez pas faire cuire des oignons de
plein de façons différentes parce que le
monde est compliqué mais mais c'est pas
la raison pure qui va vous dictez quel
plan vous considérez le meilleur parce
que c'est une émotion de dire mais je
rejette complètement le fait de
m'embêter à me faire pleurer là parce
que j'aime pas ça ou alors de les les
émotions sont peuvent être considéré
aussi comme une une heuristique de
recherche
c'est à dire que vous allez éliminé
d'emblée des plans qui parfaite qu'ils
disent de façon qu'ils sont de façon
cartésienne parfaitement valide mais
mais qui vont qui vont impliquer genre
la première étape c'est de faire un truc
que vous avez vraiment vraiment vraiment
pas c'est même pas la peine
écoutez écoutez vous parce que de toute
façon il ya plein de façons pour
résoudre les problèmes faire un truc
faire un truc que vous aimez pas c'est
peut-être inévitable parce que tous les
plans nécessaires pour résoudre le
problème bas ça va être embêtant
mais je veux dire dans la majorité des
problèmes il ya plein de façons de
résoudre un problème donc là sur ce
sujet pour commander vidéo de
présentation de jules haag lfc volkan
vulcain de paille qui est vraiment
vraiment excellent je pense qu'ils
invitent à repenser à savoir que
j'admire juillet elle et elle est
vraiment très cool un génial et ça qui a
plein de clichés qu'on associe à la
rationalité qu'en fait correspondent pas
à rationalité donc six ans et plus court
en tout cas utiliser en philosophie etc
c'est intéressant de voir qu'il ya des
émotions qui sont utiles en fait à la
rationalité par exemple la curiosité que
cette curieuse ça sera très pu que j'ai
rarement assez trouver la motivation des
arts tout ça c'est que vous pouvez du
plaisir à bien réfléchir
la motivation fait toujours partie de la
résolution du problème et je connais je
connais assez peu de gens qui arrivent à
se convaincre que pour certains
problèmes pour certains problèmes ok
mais je connaissais peu de gens qui
disent ah bah voilà j'ai trouvé le plan
ça me paraît logique je vais donc être
motivé pour le faire alors que la
motivation basse et toujours
j'aimerais bien que le problème soit
résolu ces cétacés pas vraiment c'est
pas vraiment brillé à la méthode du coup
on a parlé un peu de l'importance de
l'alignement et mais alors quels sont
les défis d'alignement pourquoi est-ce
que c'est pourquoi ça sera difficile
suffit de dire à la chine ce qu'on veut
qua non et si seulement si c'était si
simple et même même si c'était si simple
de dire à la chine ce que deviendra la
machine ce qu'on veut faudrait encore
que la machine garde soit stable dans
ces soit stable dans ses buts mais bon
certes mais c'est encore un autre
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui est qu'est ce
qui est dit alors il ya plein de il ya
plein de façon intuitive de alors le
premier problème c'est quand on va
essayer de traduire ce qu'on veut dans
des contraintes de la machine il ya on
est à peu près certain de rater des
trucs un des trucs qui est compliqué
c'est de coder codé vraiment la volonté
profonde
des humains donc si on veut aligner
aligner une machine soit un compte
encore un code vraiment la volonté
profonde des humains c'est le concept
que toi tu appelles le mois + plus que
ce qu'ils ont peint de volition
cohérente extrapolait qui dit je veux je
veux comme cibles pour ma machine
les je veux que la machine prennent les
décisions que moi je prendrais si
j'avais tout le temps d'y réfléchir
si j'avais autant de temps si j'avais
autant d'informations que j'ai besoin
pour y réfléchir
et si j'avais et si j'étais complètement
zen dans ma tête et en prenant en compte
tous les changements moreau qui pourrait
éventuellement à devenir dans le futur
bref le truc parfaitement idéal le truc
que que tu veux vraiment vraiment avec
un grand v le truc que tu ne regretteras
pas par définition
voilà un truc que tu ne peux pas
regretter la seule manière que tu
puisses relire et et ça c'est pas à
cause de toi c'est parce que tu
regrettes par exemple d'avoir pris la
pluie s'est passé cazaux d'euros mais
d'un coup tu étais dehors tu as pris
l'appli tu l'as pas regretter d'avoir
pris la pluie parce que du bon mais dans
l'absolu le truc c'est que codé ce genre
de cible c'est dur c'est dur parce que
on ne sait pas comment faire
on sait pas comment faire il ya trop de
ya trop de paramètres comme on le déduit
on n'arrivera pas vraiment à faire en
sorte que les humains le décrit
complètement il ya un truc qui s'appelle
open witch project c'est imaginons que
vous êtes en train de ta trouver une
lampe lampe à huile sur la sur la plage
tu as là qu'est ce que tu vas demander
au génie si le génie et un peu fourbe
pour que ça se passe bien
et le truc c'est que les les
contributeurs et commence à faire des
ddd des voeux de 15 pages
qui se lisent comme des contrats comme
des contrats entre multinationales
absolument sûr qu'il n'y a pas de faille
et le truc c'est que encore une fois on
est potentiellement face un système qui
est plus créatif que nous dans le sens
où il va explorer plus de trucs que nous
et va potentiellement dire ah ah tiens
il ya ce truc qui est vachement efficace
et alors je vais vérifier toutes les
règles non c'est bon donc dans un sens
un d une des difficultés du problème de
l'aliment c'est de passer c'est de
passer outre le fait que l'on puisse pas
nous mêmes
c'est la règle dessus donc il va falloir
trouver un moyen de définir de définir
ce qu'on veut alors même qu'on peux pas
le décrire donc va peut-être falloir
chercher une médaille
il ya une des médailles par exemple pour
dire on va trouver la bonne façon c'est
de dire observons nous de dire la
machine observé nous et à partir de ce
qu'on fait et c'est de déduire pourquoi
on le fait et c'est de déduire ce qui a
dans la tête des humains pour faire pour
dire voilà même si on fait tous des
erreurs même si on n'est pas super au
petit mot dans nos décisions essaie de
comprendre ce qu'on veut à partir de ce
compte fait c'est ça a été formalisée
mathématiquement par le problème de
investment learning
maintenant je vais essayer de traduire
en français apprentissage par le
renforcement coopératif inversée donc on
essaie de on essaie de faire un
processus qui apprend par l'interaction
avec les u11 verse parce que d'habitude
tu donnes un objectif et tu essaie
d'avoir une solution
là on donne la solution des humains et
on essaie de trouver les objectifs des
humains et par renforcement parce que
bon on va pas y arriver du premier coup
et on va le faire
itérative mans avait après les échanges
des humains et on va juste voilà donc
c'est une des approches pour dire ben
voilà on va donner cette cible 1
alors alors à la machine mais c'est pas
le seul problème
non parce que 1,1 d un des soucis c'est
que pour que une machine puisse prendre
de prendre de bonnes décisions et que ce
soit pas complètement que qu'elle fasse
qu'on veut une machine normalement
intelligente doit avoir une bonne
représentation du monde de
l'environnement qu'elle essaie
d'optimiser alors je vais je vais
déconstruire cette phrase unia qui joue
aux échecs ne fait pas partie du jeu
d'échecs
c'est un truc qui est hors du jeu
d'échecs qui peut simuler parfaitement
un jeu d'échecs mais qui n'est pas en
soi une pièce de jeu d'échecs
c'est un joueur sait quelque chose dom
initiant au dessus et il ya un il ya un
système qui s'appelle ayissi qui est la
définition parfaite de l'intérieur d'une
intelligence qui dit on va on va lui
donner un objectif et je vais simuler
toutes les possibilités leur probabilité
d'arrivée toutes les conséquences dans
tous les sens donc déjà ça c'est super
dur est calculée mais une faille
importante c'est que l'on suppose que
cette ce système super omniscient ne
fait pas partie du monde qu'ils
optimisent la machine ce calcul ne fait
pas partie du monde sauf que c'est pas
ce qui arrive dans la réalité c'est à
dire si vous codé ainsi si on essaie de
programmer un robot industriel genre les
bras les bras qui monte des voitures qui
doivent insérer insérer les objets à
exactement au bon endroit souvent des
mouvements bien précis ben ils ont ils
ont pas forcément dans leurs programmes
leurs propres encombrement c'est à dire
que le bras ne fait pas partie des le
bras lui même ne fait pas partie du
problème
il y a eu
et de façon plus plus plus abstraite
si une intelligence artificielle peut
agir sur le monde il qu'elle a une bonne
façon de modéliser le monde est un
moment la machine elle-même fait partie
du monde
donc il faut il faut prendre en compte
le fait que une des actions que une
machine peut faire c'est de modifier son
propre programme
ouais c'est de bidouiller ses propres
circuits et à peu dire ah bah alors il
ya ce truc dans le monde qui que si je
bidouille ces circuits et par
coïncidence ça correspond à moi même
mais en soi c'est quelque chose avant eh
ben il se trouve que ba typiquement bas
en lever les garde-fous ouais parce que
parce que parce que c'est un truc
possible et le problème c est là où ça
devient vraiment vraiment vraiment
vraiment compliqué c'est que ça devient
auto référentiel ouais c'est que si on
autorise la machine à modifier des trucs
qui ont kiki qui font leur propre conte
qui modifient leur propre comportement
le comportement il ya les mathématiques
fondamentales qui vont arriver toquer à
sa porte et te dire coucou sommes là
pour te dire que l'auto référence c'est
compliqué c'est parce qu'on a beaucoup
de mal à prouver des trucs
autoréférentielle on a déplacé et c'est
là où je vais te jeu que je pense que tu
vois à peu près à quoi je fais à quoi je
fais référence
donc si tu peux l'expliquer mieux que
moi ce serait vachement vachement cool
je pense sur le truc de maths
le truc de reparler le fait que steve
c'est c'est ça
mais le problème de l' embedded agency
le fait que un agent un agent
intelligent fait partie du monde qu'il a
obtenu en train d'optimiser on n'a pas
les armes
pour raisonner à partir de ça parce que
aujourd'hui en intelligence artificielle
quand on fait les maths qui sont
derrière l'intelligence artificielle
l'hypothèse numéro un c'est que l'agent
mais ne fait pas partie du truc qu'ils
optimisent le joueur du jeu la voiture
est un truc différent de la route sur
laquelle sur laquelle runje il ya
toujours une séparation fondamental dans
la programmation du machin entre l'agent
et son environnement
et le problème c'est que des agents
suffisamment puissant nous ne peuvent
pas ne vont pas opéré lipow cette
hypothèse là elle casse elle casse dès
le moment où on met un agent qui est
dans le monde qui peut faire des trucs
et on peut pas accepter
on peut pas on ne peut pas comment dire
c'est pas raisonnable de supposer que la
machine ne va pas se rendre compte qu'il
fait partie du monde quel optimisme
donc il nous faut un moyen de raisonner
à partir de ça et il n'ya pas les bases
il ya ya vous réellement par les bases
qu'il ya certains il ya certains groupes
donc par exemple le machine intelligence
research institute qui dit bah voilà
alors c'est très bien on essaie de
résoudre la sécurité des supers
intelligence ses shopi
on n'a pas les bases mathématiques comme
ils le disent c'est un peu comme si tu
essayé d'envoyer une fusée sur la lune
avant d'avoir compris les équations
newton cessé de dire oui non mais vous
savez on va balancer une fusée on va la
porter vers la lune
et puis dès qu'on va arriver loin bas ar
c'est pas grave si on dévie un peu de la
lune
on va pouvoir facilement sortir sortir
des petites et elle les battre et il
nous faut il nous faut des outils et là
où c'est là où c'est difficile c'est
quand on sait que
on n'a pas les outils et si on veut
avoir des garanties sur ce que va faire
des sources comment faire des ir super
puissante et il nous faut les outils
pour raisonner sur les i à ce super
puissante est temps qu'on les a pas bah
on ne peut pas espérer résoudre le
problème on va pas s'en sortir en disant
bord on va trouver on va trouver une
solution
moi personnellement je te rejoins sur ça
c'est vrai je pense que le problème de
l' embedded est bien aussi le fait que
le ya tourné sur les supports physiques
et qu'elle va être consciente qu'elle
tourne sur des supports physiques
sa voix s'est en fait c'est le plus gros
problème notamment parce que enfin
souvent les ja sont programmées avec un
objectif sur suspension et yappa
renforcement il ya un mécanisme de
récompense donc ça fonctionne par
récompenser un score qui est donné à
chaque fois il ya et qu'il va chercher à
maximiser son score et ce score elle est
calculée comme manu pas abri du coup il
ya calcul qui a lieu pour trouver ce
score se calcule en particulier a lieu
sur un support physique et il ya
pourrait modifier
enfin sur ce souci vu que son but c'est
d'avoir un maximum de récompenses
planifier des stratégies pour vacciner
ces récompenses bas elle pourrait
vouloir modifier le mécanisme physique
qui me donne sa récompense de dire bah
voila je coupe up
ces récompenses maximale du boyard
adding jaegler jeu tradition en
court-circuit le huawei le
court-circuitage jeux du cirque la
récompense est en fait c'est ce qui à ce
qui ce qui est intéressant c'est que moi
je pense qu'il ya un truc est donc
évident le monde qui a réussi à résoudre
ce point de du court circuitage les
récompenses en tout cas en partie c'est
une autre union que d'autres noms aussi
on a circuit de récompense dans la tête
est ce qu'on a réussi
alors on n'a pas à clarens entièrement
restauré réussi de trucs on était
souvent victimes de de court circuit de
récompense très souvent en cash et vous
retournez les addictions des façons de
deux d'activer circulant à compans sans
avoir à faire l'effort de raisonner à
comment ceux circulant récompense
devrait fonctionner ce que vous pourrez
dire que idéalement un cercle récompense
surtout si c'est une île puissante mais
même nous on choisira également ce qui
l'aurait faire c'est s'informer sur le
monde bien c'est de comprendre le monde
bien réfléchir à ce qui doit préférer
puis maximiser quelque chose qui va avec
quelque chose qu'il voudrait vraiment
vouloir
idéalement on voudrait que le cerveau
face à quatre mois je pense qu'on
voudrait vouloir que nous savons et eva
et moi on est capable au bois de
imaginer ce que ça pourrait être prendre
circle k de vouloir en prendre
et alors 1-1 d un décodeur inde est un
désavantage que l'humanité en fait même
vivent en général assez que l'on peut
pas modifier non on ne peut pas vous
allez bidouiller directement notre
peuple notre propre cerveau c'est-à-dire
qu'on peut on peut l'influencer
par exemple tu prends n'importe quel nom
enfin je dire n'importe quelle drogue
addictives qui va avoir des conséquences
sur le cerveau mais on peut pas se
rebrancher on peut pas se rebrancher
nous mêmes
et bah ça c'est une c'est une assez mais
j'allais dire c'est une bonne barrière
au court circuitage c'est à dire on va
pas à moins de se mettre directement une
électrode dans la tête qui va stimuler
les circuits 2 et la privée envirogaz
non non non non parce que je je je dis
ça mais il ya eu quelques expériences
qui ont été faites à l'époque où
à l'époque on avait moins de scrupules à
faire ce genre de l'époque on avait
moins de scrupules à faire ce genre
d'expérience de dire 'voilà mettre une
électrode dans la tête et un petit
bouton pour dire voilà à chaque fois que
vous appuyez sur ce bouton ça va envoyer
un une impulsion dans la partie du
cerveau qui est responsable d d des
récompenses en fin dé se sentir oui
c'est très bien qu'est ce qui va se
passer ça assez mal fini en fait je
crois qu'une d'aidé alors à vérifier en
référence nécessaire tout ça mais que ça
s'est fini en la personne a appuyé sur
le bouton on l'a on l'avait fait sur des
rats aussi ça c'est ça s'est fait à peu
près de la même façon mais maintenant le
problème publié un des indes est un des
garde-fous qui ont des garde-fous qui
sont là c'est que généralement de façon
évolutive balles et les humains qui
commence à court circuiter leur circuit
le font au détriment de d'autres
fonctions typiquement reproduction tout
ça qui font que quoi que ce soit
quelques prédispositions par exemple
génétique qui fait qu' ils font que ils
tombent dans ce piège ne va pas être
transmises à l'heure alors descendre là
où ça là où ça commencerait à être très
intéressant c'est s'il ya un truc
extrêmement une mutation bizarre qui
fait que les gens veulent se reproduire
vraiment un maximum et que et que du
coup le fait que cette mutation soit se
reproduire un maximum bas elles
s'étendent à l'intégralité de la
population
sauf qu'en fait ça c'est pas une
hypothèse c'est exactement ce qui est
arrivé
je veux dire c'est par défaut le
processus de sélection fait que le
sélectionne les gens qui court circuite
un maximum leur qui concerne qui est un
maximum leurs circuits de sorte à poux à
ce que les jeunes survivent jusqu'à ce
qu'il ya d'autres contraintes qui arrive
alors du coup c'est ça vraiment court
circuit ça se court circuitent pour la
reproduction
mais c'est pas un court-circuit
directement pour les zones du plaisir
ses missions y ait ce qui est déjà pas
mal quoi c'est oui mais
mais là où ça devient encore plus encore
plus fun c'est que au bout du bout d'un
certain temps
l'humanité s'est rendu compte de ce
processus maintenant on arrive à
comprendre
maintenant on arrive à comprendre
l'évolution et on comprend un peu les
comprends un peu les les incitations qui
ont été construites par des milliers
d'années d'évolution
mais le truc c'est que on n'a pas à les
suivre
ouais c'est ça c'est joué on n'a pas à
les suivre c'est à dire on a peut-être
inscrit dans notre cerveau qui a évolué
dans des le l'envi de se reproduire en
moyenne
c'est nous emmène mais ça nous en fait
ne nous empêche pas de de mettre des
préservatifs mais parce que on s'est dit
ah il ya ce genre d'activités qui nous
procure du plaisir
eh bien faisons le mais sans sans avoir
à 100 mais juste pas à des fins de
reproduction
juste parce que c'est cool ouais et
bezina on a court circuité l'évolution
ouais c'est clair c'est ça c'est bizarre
c'est dans le conte voudrait vouloir
aujourd'hui n'a pas l'air d'être ce que
les jeunes nous pousserait c'est
absolument pressé on a on n'est plus
aligné avec l'europe avec avec les eaux
là je vais dire on n'est plus aligné
avec l'eurovision l'eurovision n'est pas
aligné avec l'évolution on n'est plus
aligné avec l'évolution l'évolution
optimiste pour un truc l'évolution
optimiste pour mon repos ont reproduit
les jeunes c'est pas un optimiseur dans
le sens alpha go c'est un optimiseur
dans le sens le processus de sélection
le processus de reproduction le
processus de nier ligne a fait une
pression sur nous de sorte à ce que on
va probablement arriver à des à des
populations qui qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
veulent se reproduire qui se
reproduisent effectivement et qui
s'adaptent à leur environnement parce
que sinon ils pourraient pas avoir le
temps se reproduire ni avenir mais mais
mais nous sommes d'aidé parce que on est
capable de raisonner sur ce qu'on fait
d'avoir deux parce qu un peu de barmon
va dire le fait qu' on va dire on est
arrivé à un point où l'humanité pour
survivre avait besoin de représenter le
monde mais il se trouve qu'en s'est
représenté nous et on arrive à être
suffisamment conscients de 2,2 pourquoi
on en est là pour dire ben voila je
connais l'objectif de l'évolution et
j'en ai rien à faire
c'est la ccc et aidants et dans un sens
et je veux dire c'est à dire c'est pas
cool mais mais on est on sait c on s'est
pas libérée de tout là on va dire la
psychologie évolutive
c'est à dire par exemple si tu prends
on a des clés pour comprendre certains
éléments de notre technologie qui
viennent de qui viennent de l'évolution
qui viennent millions d'années mais le
problème c'est que c'est extrêmement
incomplet c'est à dire qu' il ya des
trucs de tout le tout les tout l'étude
de la société de tout l'étude des
humains des relations complexes qu'on a
avec le monde avec des technologies que
l'évolution n'a certainement pas prévu
dans le code génétique
tout ce qui lie toutes des relations des
relations de pouvoir des interactions
entre des millions et des millions de
personnes des trucs qui sont juste
largement au delà de ce que peut prédire
la psychologie évolutive et qui va
falloir étudier et ben c'est enfin
j'allais dire que j'allais dire qu'une
bonne une grosse grosse partie des
sciences sociales vient combler le vient
d'écrire des enfants c'est l'exemple
même du fait qu' on a complètement
diverger de ce que l'évolution voulait
pendre
enfin vous voulez pour nous les
individus on s'en fiche l'important
c'est la survie de l'espèce
mais vous le voulez pour les trucs
qu'elle optimisée et puis voyez la cdac
et sa façon de voir ça de l'évolution ce
qu'on voudrait vouloir sous l'angle de
l'évolution
parce que finale et il ya quasiment des
trucs des objectifs qu'ils aient
instrumentaux comme par exemple la
curiosité comme utile d'avoir des des
individus qui voulaient en savoir plus
parce qu'ils s'adaptent sûrement oui
mais une mathématicien enfin quasiment
un objectif final aujourd'hui c'est à
ces jeux comment dire c est en étant par
exemple je suis très curieux d'avoir le
connaître la fin du bouquin que je suis
en train de lire
mais je veux dire là je suis en train de
hacker un circuit de curiosité qui use
aurait été probablement plus curieux de
voir ce qu'ils avaient dans le buisson
derrière mais mais mais en soit je vais
pas dire il est bon que je vais pas
justifier ma curiosité de lire le
bouquin en disant ah ça c'est parce que
ça c'est ça c'est parce que je voulais
lire je voulais aller voir l'ambition
d'air est juste je vais me trouver
d'autres raisons
je suis plus je suis je suis plus je
suis plus rate les dire je suis plus
rattachées à mes besoins primaires c'est
un peu prétentieux comme ça absolument
faux nom mé sak lé est l'objectif les
objectifs que se fixent les hommes ont
beaucoup évolué au cours des derniers
siècles effet il ya plus il ya plus de
raison qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient alignés avec l'évolution
tout quand alors et pour pour boucler
justement c'est une des d'ailleurs une
des objections qui dit de toute façon
une intelligence artificielle n'aura pas
des buts stupides comme l'intelligence
artificielle va naturellement se rendre
compte que transformer l'univers
en trombone et stupide mais de la même
façon que nous si on discutait et si on
discutait avec avec l'incarnation de
avec l'incarnation anthropomorphes ise
de l'évolution en à l'heure lui
expliquer voire alors voilà maintenant
on joue à des jeux vidéo des bouquins on
peint des trucs l'évolution nous
regarderait comme ça une 10 mai mais
qu'est ce que c'est mais qu'est ce que
vous êtes en train de faire et c'est
complètement stupide bas il n'y a pas de
raison que une intelligence artificielle
10 ben voila moi j'ai été optimisé pour
ça donc je fais tel truc tel truc tel
truc et nous on est là il y met mais non
il n'y a pas de y'a pas de raison il n'y
a pas de raison que si on optimise pour
un truc qui n'est pas par construction
aligné avec avec ses créateurs il n'y a
pas de raison que ça restait lié saisi
jeudi
c'est l'exploit de l'exploration c'est
peu on peut qu'on peut on peut tellement
faire des trucs mais il ya peut
maximiser à peu près n'importe quoi y'a
bien non pour ça d'ailleurs la thèse de
locaux tests de l'automne de leur
tonalité les unes une intelligence
arbitraire peut maximiser un objectif
arbitraire et oui je fais une vidéo de
suivi d'une petite vidéo de robert ont
très bien ils ont cherché sur google il
ya la salsa jardin du livre de boston
ouais ouais c'est bien bostrom qui qu'il
a fait mais c'était pas d'un super
l'intelligence le bouquin c'était moins
de papier avant
et c'était c'était dans un papier a
vraiment aimé oui c'était sébastien
ouais bah du coup qui qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
est-ce que tu auras des conseils à
donner par les auditeurs qui voudraient
aider
qu'est-ce qui peut être oui plein un
plein alors là la première est la
première chose c'est que si c'est la
première fois que vous entendez parler
de ses trucs et que ça vous semble
intéressant la première chose à faire
c'est de lire des trucs dessus
c'est alors c'est c2c de réfléchir
dessus c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup
bon il ya une probabilité très élevée
pour que les premières intuitions que
vous ayez d'autres les ai vus avant vous
que certaines intuitions que vous ayez
soit fausse mais c'est pas grave le on
est un des premiers conseil que je peux
donner c'est de de dire bon ben voilà de
réfléchir à la question me dire à quoi
ça à quoi ça correspond de discuter avec
des gens qui se posent les mêmes
questions de voir un peu ce que les gens
ont fait avant avant avant même de
vouloir dire qu'est ce que je peux y
faire parce que encore une fois oui
la der à toi à titre personnel comment
comprendre comment est ce que tu as des
couleurs comme ça ce qu'est laiteries
qui tomberont choqué la question
dentition horrible put alors j'ai dit m
alors j'ai gémit j'ai mis beaucoup de
temps à faire à faire le tour du
problème mais un peu aussi parce que je
suis passé par parce que je suis passé
par les orgues
parce que je suis passé d'abord par les
trucs eu de casse qui voulait qu'on lise
avant que je suis j'ai peut-être eu le
le privilège d'avoir moins d'un tuyau
fausse parce que je suis passé par
toutes les étapes et que nenê n'est que
et qu'on m'a pas juste balance et est ce
que tu as entendu parler du problème de
l'alignement c'est super important
vraiment appris découvert le produit du
mans où les risques de dix ans après
avoir fait ce parcours de ouais ouais
c'est à dire que j'étais déjà à ce
moment là en fait je vais déjà j'avais
déjà ah bah oui oui je vais répondre moi
pas question comme ça du coup c'est que
je vais déjà commencer mon doctorat en
intelligence artificielle
ouais c'est pas ça qui m'a motivé à
faire la beauce et dans l'intelligence
artificielle ce qui m'a motivé c'est
parce que je suis un gros flemmard c'est
à dire que quand j'étais au lycée je
voulais qu'il y ait des machines et avec
lesquels je puisse discuter pendant les
cours parce que c'était bardon et je
voulais qu'il fasse mais mes devoirs à
ma place je me suis rendu compte que
c'est un peu plus compliqué que prévu
mais j'étais fascinée par tout ce qui
était robot je me dis ah ouais je vais
construire des machines qui est jeu
conçu grâce à la machine qui fabrique
des trucs m et pourquoi je ferai pas des
machines qui construisent des machines
qui construisent des trucs et et à force
de me documenter sur le truc comme
disant comment on fait j'ai découvert le
domaine d'intelligence artificielle est
comme ça m'intéressait toujours et que
je me disais c'est génial ben j'ai
continué mes études de dents jusqu'à
fait un doctorat dessus mais c'est que
et au début je me disais banon j'étais
carrément dans le camp du c'est génial
génial je vais faire des machines qui
font des machines qui font des machines
et tout ira parfaitement bien et j'étais
un mode jeu j'avais découvert le concept
genre de singularité et même de 10 ans à
oui alors il ya plusieurs
alors attention lorsque je parle de
singularité mais il ya plusieurs il ya
plusieurs trucs qui sont qui sont
entendus par par singularité c'est c'est
encore un mot il ya tellement de coupe
derrière que l on peut partir dans tous
les sens il ya ya ya ya
il ya singularité dans le sens ça va
le progrès suit une courbe suit une
courbe exponentielle un sens où on va
compresser le temps qu'on met entre deux
innovations et que à partir du moment le
progrès va littéralement être
complètement infinie et après on sait
pas c'est une des ses unes d une d une d
une des définitions
il y en a d'autres la deuxième c'est un
moment on va faire un truc tellement
kikoo que on saura plus ce qu'il ya
derrière on ne peut pas prédire au delà
d'une certaine puissance fugue et la
troisième c'est on va créer un truc qui
fait du progrès plus vite que nous parce
que c'est plus nous qui sommes le moteur
principal du progrès et le truc c'est
que les trois définitions se recoupent
un peu mais si tu vas au bout de chaque
définition ça donne des trucs
extrêmement différents donc bref le truc
c'est que ben moi je vais entendu parler
de parler de singularité et tout était
extrêmement confus dans ma tête
ouais et là je commence à lire à lire à
lire les ongs et là je me rends compte
que ben il ya des gens qui ont vraiment
réfléchi à la question et que il ya
peut-être moyen de non seulement
réfléchir à la question mais de deux de
se confronter aux problèmes qui sont
soulevés par ça ouais donc j'ai donc ça
a commencé à déconstruire un problème
mes intuitions sur sur le sujet et je
pense que mon parcours dedans j'ai jean
marie vin j'en arrivais en j'arrive à
expliquer ces concepts cc c'est ce dont
on parle et c'est ce dont parlait au
début c'est à dire que tu pense avoir
compris un concept et si tu essaies de
l'expliquer tu as mal expliqué
et au début je l'expliquais juste très
très mal maintenant j'estime que je
l'expliqué un peu mieux et là j'ai
l'impression que de même de l'avoir de
l'avoir je l'expliquais jeu l'âge
l'expliquent dans cette discussion avec
toi très différemment de la façon dont
je l'expliquerai à une audience que je
connais en préparant des slides en
préparant une présentation bien formaté
mais ces ions de m'adapter à ce que je
pense que l'on dit on se connaît parce
que là je ne sais pas qui va écouter
notre conversation
donc là je fais et je sais que toi tu es
déjà que tu es déjà familiers avec ce
genre de problème donc j'ai beaucoup de
mal à calibrer mon explication
donc j'ai je vais voir tendance à
bafouiller affaire dé faire des trucs et
peut-être juste peut-être que dans
quelques années j'aurai suffisamment
expliqué les trucs pour avoir
naturellement sans bafouiller pouvoir
expliquer à n'importe qui en claquant
des doigts
le problème de l'alignement et toutes
ses ramifications
j'en suis mais j'en suis pas encore là
par exemple quelqu'un que j'estime
beaucoup plus loin sur le sujet bon
évidemment ça va être une cause qui est
encore ioukos qui dit lui même qu'il ait
pas un très bon orateur il écrit des
trucs mais il écrit très rarement des
bouquins il écrit plus des posts de blog
parce que c'est ce massif mais c'est pas
un très très bon orateur quelqu'un qui
est plus long que moi aussi ses robes
miles qui en est à sa chaîne et qui
parlent beaucoup et j'aimerais beaucoup
faire la même chose que lui le strat
izard de nouvelles chaînes youtube
alors alors techniquement la chaîne
youtube est déjà créée elle a exactement
0 vidéo si j'arrive à me motiver je sais
pas quand est-ce que tu compte sortir
cet épisode mais je vais tenter de
sortir une première vidéo dessus même il
y avait une première vidéo de suis gelé
supprimer parce que j'étais assez
content bon on s'en fout le don coinche
gg j'ai envie de m'entraîner deux
et d'essayer d'expliquer ces trucs mieux
beaucoup mieux
donc si vous êtes intéressés peut-être
je leur expliquerai un autre moment mais
bah je veux je veux aussi en faire un
peu ma carrière aussi c'est à dire que
ce que je voudrais jeu ce que je
voudrais faire dans cinq dix ans c'est
dans la plus pure dans le plus pur dans
la plus pure tradition de l'altruisme
efficace consacrer ma carrière à
résoudre un problème potentiellement
négligé sur lequel je pourrais avoir un
impact majeur
espérons qu'ils aient de tenter de faire
de la gouvernance c'est-à-dire de faire
ce que fait obama ya et en disant bon
bah on va essayer de d'envoyer les bons
signaux de faire un sort que les gens
prennent les bonnes décisions vis-à-vis
d'intelligence artificielle d'essayer
d'anticiper les transformations de la
société d'essayer de discuter un maximum
avec les avec les gens qui font des
recherches techniques et de les rendre
digeste de de les rendre accessibles au
plus de gens et de dire voilà il ya ce
ces gens qui font de la recherche qui
dont l'utilité reste à part reste à
démontrer mais reste à montrer au monde
et il ya un gros boulot là dessus et moi
j'ai des compétences techniques j'aime
bien programmé tout ça mais je suis pas
je cite un mathématicien dans l'âme et
je me dis peut-être peut-être je
pourrais faire des jeux juste orienté
orienté l'ia du futur dans une
dans une direction qui a une meilleure
probabilité de ne pas faire n'importe
quoi votre trop cool et et tout ceci le
conseil que du goût du conseil à un peu
aussi aux joueurs d'essayer 2 - suivre
les premières étapes
c'est ce que tu racontes cei a essayé de
s'informer déjà sur sexuelle intime mais
aussi peut-être même surtout ici seuil
est de les clarifier d'eux en fait je
n'aime pas répondu à ta question
originelle je suis parti sur une table
jeune couple c'est là le premier conseil
s'était s'informer ouais et le truc
c'est que si vous vous informer que vous
commencez à vous poser des questions
à force de vous poser des questions vous
allez vous retrouver devant des plans
développe par exemple vous allez vous
poser la question quel est le meilleur
plan pour atteindre cet objectif
quel est le meilleur plan pour pour
avoir un grand impact
quel est quels sont les plans possibles
pour rire ce problème et il se trouve
que si vous cherchez suffisamment
longtemps
vous avez de grandes chances de tomber
sur un plan
que vous pouvez mettre en oeuvre une d
une d une d1 des humains des conseils de
carrière dans nos communautés de la
surprise mais efficace c'est justement
de deux d'aller un peu plus vite dans
cette dans cette recherche
en dix ans partait un peu de ce que vous
savez faire et guider un peu votre
recherche à partir de ce que vous savez
faire mais c'est un peu piégeux
parce que parce que les gens peuvent
apprendre de nouveaux domaines peuvent
découvrir de nouveaux trucs donc faut
pas forcément se limiter à ce que vous
pensez à un domaine où vous pensez être
bon et lorsque si ça se trouve en vous
informant sur les problèmes vous allez
me dire mais en fait ça me botte très
bien de bosser là dessus ce serait cool
et vous allez essayer des trucs et vous
allez donc s'informer et à force de
s'informer vous
il va y avoir un déclic à qui veut pas y
avoir un mais mais mais au minimum vous
avez vous allez vous retrouver dans une
situation où vous même si c'est si vous
informer sur des problèmes qui me
tiennent à coeur que vous allez pouvoir
avoir une compréhension suffisamment
bonne du problème que vous pouvez au
minimum en parler à d'autres gens et
peut-être que c'est hors de gens vont se
retrouver à trouver des planches sur
lesquels ils peuvent sur lesquels ils
peuvent agir donc dans tous les cas
c'est c'est quasiment tout bénef
c'est c'est jeu je veux dire si vous
êtes si vous êtes curieux que vous vous
si vous essayez d'entretenir cette
curiosité en essayant de dire je veux
résoudre des problèmes je veux
comprendre le monde
je veux je veux m'amuser et je veux dire
à un moment et et aussi parce qu'il faut
pas négliger sa si vous êtes prêts si
vous êtes ouvert à genre à rejoindre une
communauté qui se pose ce genre de
question
ceci est un appel du pied extrêmement
petite île mais si vous voulez résoudre
des problèmes vous n'êtes pas seuls et
juste insister sur chacun des points de
l'italie mais surtout le côté
communautaire est vraiment important
parce que j'ai besoin de 26 et en
dialoguant rebondissements sont des
idées on est on des retours et sup aussi
dans la bonne ambiance de joie et la
bonne humeur
acheter des bateaux c'est ultra utilisé
c'est vraiment un truc qui fait une
énorme différence et surtout sur sur ce
genre de problème c'est facile de
commencer à paniquer énormément parce
que d'une diva à la fin du monde est en
jeu est ce que je suis en train de 2 est
ce que je suis en train de paniquer tout
seul dans mon coin pour rien est ce que
je suis en train de devenir fou juste
non pas forcément
si vous rencontrez des gens qui disent
ouais ben non tu tu fais tu fais tu dis
n'importe quoi c'est juste si si ça vous
aussi si vous tombez sur des trucs
vraiment contre intuitif il ya peut-être
moyen que vous ayez raison c'est un peu
la limite il ya eu quelques discussions
récentes sur quand est-ce qu'il faut
écouter les experts ou par une poêle et
parfois il ya certains problèmes ou si
vous faites votre si vous faites votre
vos calculs dans vos coins là vous allez
trouver un truc qui contredit tous que
qui contredit ce que les experts disent
et là il ya 2 il ya deux il ya à peu
près de deux façons d'y arriver c'est
soit vous en parlez howett
soit vous en parler aux experts ils vont
dire pourquoi votre solution est
complètement fausse auquel cas vous
allez mettre à jour soit vous allez
parler aux experts qui vont vous donner
les raisons
qui ne vous font pas ce qui ne vous font
pas qu'ils nous font pas changer d'avis
mais mais en étant enfin qui ne vous
font pas changer d'avis dans le sang se
connecter intellectuelle c'est à dire
que les raisons données par les experts
sont pas de bonnes raisons parce que
c'est possible parce que parce que c'est
possible d'avoir raison contre eux il
est possible d'avoir raison contre une
majorité d'experts avec des énormes
énorme énorme énorme guillemets sur ce
que je dis parce que quand on entend ça
d'habitude c'est aaa
ça veut dire que ma conspiration est
probablement vrai jeu non c'est c'est
juste que les experts sont pas
infaillibles et que si vous avez des
preuves extraordinaires
ça peut être suffisant pour retourner
pour avoir un impact extraordinaire
au parfois parfois ça marche parfois ça
marche envers et contre tout c'est dans
un sens ou faux pas de jeu
comment dirais je dis ça parce que lee
hae beaucoup de problèmes sur lesquels
sur lesquels les l'altruisme efficace
travail sondés sont des problèmes qui
vont être contre elle critique pour la
majorité et le truc c'est que être
contre intuitif en soi c'est pas ça n'a
pas de valeur
ça peut être contre intuitif et faut
c'est être contre actifs est vrai mais
c'est pas parce que c'est contre
intuitif que c'est automatiquement faux
parce que les intuitions
c'est pas parce que c'est contre les
experts que c'est automatiquement faut
donc il ya aurait tendance à considérer
l'avis des experts comme les trucs qu'il
faut absolument regarder pour éviter les
erreurs mais c'est pas une parole
d'évangile n'est
donc c'est la la la la curiosité peut
pas être contrainte vers ce qui est ce
qui est consensuelle
c'est à dire dire je je je je suis je
suis un peu vague là dessus désolé là
bas se souvient j'étais recommandé le
lift de deux têtes locke qui peut-être
locke qui s'appelle support casting qui
est un livre qui étudie les gens qui
passent alors c'est assez difficile
d'essayer d'identifier des gens qui
prédisent bien parce que souvent ils ont
réglé disent tout et n'importe quoi et
il n'y a pas de trac récurrent de trois
corps n'y a pas de difficile de tenir
d'historique
et puis souvent c'est des prédictions
assez vagues assez floue 500
probabilités et puis elle vieillit du
survivant qui fait que parmi cent mille
gens qui font des productions il y en a
au moins quatre ou cinq qui vont avoir
bon juste juste sur un coup de bol
quatre fois de suite et ça ça ne fait
pas de ddd bondé bon prédicteur donc
c'est met donc peut-être locle où il a
étudié il a fait des recherches sur des
gens qui étaient partis car en moins
utilisée a suivi la vérifient qu'ils
étaient bons en terme de prédiction est
dans ce livre il partage un peuple et
les observations qu'il a fait sur la
différence entre ceux qui prédisent bien
ceux qui prédisent prévient et en
particulier sur les experts pensent que
c'est intéressant de se demander
pourquoi est ce que ces experts sont
considérés experts et et à ce que ça ça
justifie qu'il soit meilleur en
prédictions sur quel jeu peut arriver
que par exemple des experts soient
devenus experts parce qu'il maîtrise
très bien une technique mais pour
prédire le coût le futur quelque chose
qui est pas directement liée uniquement
à leur technique
bah ils puissent être pas forcément très
très bon et comment par exemple de façon
très très bas et vienne
le livre au site ultra pro balayant ça
c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'aspects
de l'estuaire forecaster qui sont guère
c'est considérer bay street
le taux de base le taux de base
et puis faire des estimations de fermer
à des couples où est le problème
je recommande vivement pour ceux qui se
posent des questions sur comment
commencer à voir des choses à moi aussi
bon je suis fatigué possible en pratique
je me joins cette recommandation ouais
ce cadeau 80 trucs que les gens
pourraient faire pour donc voilà donc je
pense que c'est clairement un besoin
aussi de 46 aussi dessus mais s'informer
sur ces questions des ultras contre un
titi comme qui attendent de ne pas y
aller avec l'intuition tout cas pas
uniquement avec l'intuition passé c'est
vraiment très très piégeux beaucoup se
questionner essayer de dialoguer en
groupes ou communautés
c'est ça c'est très important
s'entraîner a expliqué être pédagogue
essayer des trucs les airs c'est pas
facile c'est difficile et c'est de ne
pas avoir peur de pas avoir peur d'avoir
ne pas avoir peur de se planter c'est à
dire aussi c'est vous allez vous allez
probablement vous plantez l'importance
et vous tombez vous relever c'est bon je
me suis je me suis trompé bas c'est
grave
ok maintenant je vais me rapprocher un
peu plus de la vérité et je vais pas
m'arrêter pour ça aussi je conseille
aussi pas mal les marqueurs de modestie
épistémique c'est plus facile de repas
un conseil de comté quand on a montré
des hésitations
c'est le way il ya ya ya un plan
j'arrive pas à le traduire en français
mais il ya une locution qui dit strang
vif weekend c'est à dire de deux d'être
très convaincus de ce qu'on dit mais de
lâcher prise facilement si jamais si
jamais on se trompe
c'est à dire que 1 il ya une partie de
ya un échec de la modestie dans le sang
si jamais on dilue on dilue ses propres
on dilue ses propres ses propres
convictions
le le but c'est de dire je pense
vraiment ça donc je vais décider dessus
en disant ok je suis pas à cent pour
cent sûr mais j'ai pris ça en compte
dans ma décision et je vais rester
modeste dans le sens où je vais accepter
qu'il ya un risque que je me trompe et
je suis prêt à reconsidérer mes
positions si je me trompe mais quelqu'un
qui nique et qu'ils sont c'est pas de
dire c'est pas de dire je suis à 99% sur
d'un truc mais c'est un peu c'est pas
assez modeste de dire ça donc je vais
arbitrairement décidé de baisser sa à 80
% parce que sinon ce serait pas assez
modeste ouais la modestie s'est passé la
modestie verra c'est parce ça ne doit
pas être ça c'est juste de dire je suis
je suis je suis raisonnablement certains
mais mais je peux me tromper je pense
vraiment vraiment vraiment pas que je
joue tron mais je suis pas arrogant au
point de dire c'est comme ça puis c'est
tout mais c'est utile de distinguer
enfin c'est une escale en partant de la
rue marca que parce que j'avais marqueur
de me décider ouais que ça c'est juste
essayé de dire le bon degré de confiance
qu'on a en différents que je crois oui
oui et donc il ya des choses sur
lesquelles on peut être très
raisonnablement largement très confiant
que je pense que je peux dire que je
suis à peu près sûr que il n'ya pas
aligner est extrêmement dangereuse si
elle est puissante
j'en suis aussi quasiment certain
mais il ya d'autres choses sur quels
types bien certain qu'il y règne à deux
niveaux humain ça les fusils certitude
que cette vaste question
j'aimerais ne pas en parler ça prendrait
trop de temps et j'ai pas envie ça peut
ne pas en parler c'est une autre fois
juste une fois cc c'est trop vaste et
j'ai tendance à perdre mes cheveux à
chaque fois que j'en parle
et puis sinon dans la discussion mais
bayonne longue flèche dont on n'entend
graff de lien causal entre les dents la
discussion mais l'exploration et
l'exploitation je pense que le fait d'
explorer aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya vraiment besoin de
d'exploits et beaucoup plus de domaines
si vous voulez savoir quels cas la cause
avec elle devrait consacrer votre temps
voir votre carrière
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya vraiment
besoin de beaucoup plus exploration dire
que on est résilient des millions de
choses y compris au chômage
mais il ya vraiment besoin de santé has
et a beaucoup beaucoup de choses mais tu
restes en faisant quoi nous intéresse a
beaucoup de choses et en particulier
dans le domaine de l'image je pense que
ça se fasse a voulu très très vite à
faire mon travail mais aussi au niveau
de la effective la spécification s'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui évoluent pour
m'aider à électrique qui ont beaucoup
grossi au cours des années il y aura
sans doute encore beaucoup de choses à
faire à venir bien d'un jeu plutôt que
de nous investir directement sur une
tâche très précis je pense que c'est
vraiment plus le moment en ce moment de
d'explorer de vous préparer à faire des
choses peut-être très différent de ce
que vous faites aujourd'hui
ouais ouais mais yahia il est plein il
ya plein de domaines si j'avais
l'objectif c'est un des objectifs c'est
de comprendre le monde et à plainte et
le monde et je viens monde est compliqué
c'est pas c'est juste c'est hier c'est
pas en disant moi je fais de la je fais
de la biologie donc je vais à
complètement à fond dans la biologie et
puis tout le reste pour me forcer à
chaque chaque domaine à sa façon de de
comprendre de représenter parfois de
prédire le monde
il ya des gars de l'information partout
sous des formes sous des formes énorme
et bas etc c'est quasiment toujours une
bonne idée d'avoir plusieurs plusieurs
points de vue mais pas donc pas dans le
sens plusieurs points de vie plusieurs
opinions divergentes mais plusieurs
manières de regarder un même un même
problème le sens plus littéral c'est à
dire des points à partir desquels voir
ses seins je sais ça je pense que c'est
vraiment intéressant et puis surtout je
pense qu'il ya de plus en plus de
besoins d'interdisciplinarité oui rien
que dans ces discussions d on a parlé de
trucs de biologie de notions soir devant
il ya besoin de gens matic et
mathématiques qui a vraiment besoin de
pas mal d expertise pour beaucoup de
questions et il ya un manque de trains
ter disciplinarité en ce moment et je
pense que il y aura des 102 sans devoir
nécessairement être expert d'un dante ou
par exemple il a tout à l'heure quand
j'ai commencé à parler psychologie
évolutive j'ai eu une énorme alarme dans
ma tête en disant attention jérémy tu
n'est absolument pas un expert dans ce
domaine ne te fais pas allumé sur
twitter s'il te plaît pour l'instant ça
m'est pas encore arrivé j'ai pas en quoi
je vais pas je m'estime heureux ça
arrivera je je je je suis prêt personne
n'est prêt non mais c'est bien on va
dire que si je dis si j'ai dit des
bêtises dedans et que les gens sont
absolument certain que j'ai dit des
bêtises
venez m'a expliqué les trucs juste venez
m'expliquer les trucs le pire qui puisse
arriver c'est pas que je comprenne pas
non le non jeu non c'est pas ça le au
pire au pire je répondrai pas pire
au pire je répondrai pas mais mais mais
d'un sens parce que j'aurais juste
oublié de répondre c'est à dire que si
vous faites une bonne explication est
que j'estime que j'ai appris des trucs
bah je vais je vais répondre twitté
faire un truc je vais me dire ok ok
j'avais j'avais des imprécisions dessus
je j'ai appris des trucs voila voila je
vais je vais booster le booster le
signal de ce truc parce que j'estime que
si moi j'ai fait l'erreur et que et que
j'ai appris des trucs va peut-être que
les gens qui ont le même raison
raisonnante mois peuvent profiter de
l'explication qui vient de bien de qui
vient de m'être donné mais partie h f
si on a dit des bêtises et que vous les
critiquez vous soyez s'il vous plaît
bien en pédagogue claire et bennoo va
comprendre
oui enfin parce que dans l'absolu c'est
si si vous voulez aussi si vous voulez
répondre à haquin qui voulait faire en
sorte que 15 et enfin si on parle c'est
qu'on a tort 1-1 d une un truc cool
c'est que c'est que vous n'ayez pas vous
répéter ça s est essayé de multiplier
votre impact en donnant la meilleure
version de votre argument c'est à dire
un truc que vous pourrez utiliser pour
corriger tous les to les clampins tous
les tous les hérétiques les tous les
tous les to les ignorants ou juste tous
les débutants et tous les curieux qui
peuvent apprendre
si vous avez des connaissances à
partager nous ne nous ne sommes pas
votre ennemi votre votre ennemi votre
ennemi à la rigueur c'est l'ignorance
votre ennemi c'est le danger qu'ils
représentent
les gens qui font des prédictions
fausses le danger c'est des gens qui
font des décisions si vous sembleront
erroné parce que vous estimez que les
gens savent pas les trucs
l'objectif c'est l'objectif c'est
d'expliquer pourquoi tout le monde
puisse prendre de meilleures décisions
c'est serré c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles les attaques ad hominem se
sont juste un peu inutile c'est que la
disquette disqualifié disqualifié
quelqu'un part parce que eux parce
qu'ils ont même pas sa tête
ben ok soit ça peut-être disqualifié
mais ce n'est pas ça la panouse à ça ça
va pas nous nous faire progresser plus
vite dans la recherche de la vérité bon
sens là il n'y aura moi pas très bien à
coups de balles or l'enseignement c'est
que d'enseigner démarre à quelqu'un
suffit pas du cri du coeur là
franchement tu connais pas le résultat
tu sais pas faire une intégrale tweed
sait pas faire une intégration par
partie mais où est ce que tu es allé je
suis prêt à faire ça ça plante se
montrent
j'en peux plus mais ouais c'est à chaque
débat tant mieux est-ce que tu auras
d'autres choses à rajouter sur ces genre
de truc auquel je vais je vais avoir une
réponse dans à peu près une heure à
parler encore mais je sais et je sais
que j'ai raté des trucs alors on va
hockey récapitulation très rapide à quoi
je pense je pensais que dans cette
discussion on allait parler de chaque
liste alignement alignement de
l'intelligence artificielle pourquoi
c'est important pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi comment pourquoi
probablement dans les prisons efficace
ça c'est bon qu'on allait parler de mon
parcours mais ça c'est normal c'est
toujours au début qu'il ya des trucs
qu'on allait parler de problèmes en
débattre et d'épistémologie mais sans
mentionner le mans épistémologie mais de
meda prend tissage de curiosité tout ça
et non c'était les points principaux et
je crois qu'on les a tous et je crois
qu'on les a tous les atouts c'est bardé
on n'a pas parlé de ton livre je veux
bien faire je veux bien faire je veux
bien faire un jeu juste d un truc qui me
parlait qui me paraissait important
j'ai lu la version 2 de ton livre tu as
fait relire à des gens de tous horizons
et 7
c'est génial et je veux dire c'est un
des indes est une des rares publications
en français sur le thème de deux de
l'intelligence artificielle vraiment
futur du problème de l'alignement le
seul autre que je connais c'est la
traduction française du livre de nick
bostrom super intelligence agency dia
oasis de telle marque qui a été traduit
la vie tree of life 3.0 ah oui et être
vigilant il en parle un peu mais c'est
juste sait on va dire c'est un chapitre
c'est un chapitre ou deux mais j'aime
beaucoup l'histoire qui a au début et au
début du bouquin c1 c'est un excellent
une excellente histoire
si vous connaissez rien aux pointes de
28 ans artificiel pour maintenant vous
connaissez un peu plus écouté pendant
plus de deux heures à dire je
conseillerais de concept plutôt par
celui de telle marque que celui de
boston qui boostera mais très très
académique tag marquer beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus dans une
optique de vulgarisation et
d'exploration est vachement chouette
mais il ya encore trop peu de ressources
en français c'est à dire que là on a
parlé de les wang on a parlé de plein de
deux concepts la première fois qu'on les
mentionner c'était en anglais et à
chaque fois on essayait de trouver des
traductions
ceci n'est pas un hasard
il ya vraiment peu de vraiment peu de
trucs en français et j'apprécie beaucoup
la contribution bon au moment où on
enregistre futur du bouquin à ça je
croise vraiment les doigts pour qu'il
ait pour qu'il ait l'impact que que que
toi et mehdi vous vouliez qui voulait
qu'il est je crois le jeu croisons les
doigts et le truc c'est que comme ya
plein de contenus en en anglais il ya
une question à laquelle je voudrais une
réponse mais il ya que les auditeurs qui
peuvent répond c'est combien qu'elles
sont quelle est la proportion des
auditeurs qui sont qui préféreraient
vraiment mieux avoir des contenus en
français plutôt que d'aller fouiller les
contenus en anglais parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de contenu en anglais
quand je parle de la zon gachot fob ça
ça jamais été traduits en français
la fabrique harry potter peut-être a été
mis à des contenus et malgorn qui est la
grande question gcs qu'il faut vraiment
des trucs en français pour si vous êtes
curieux sur ces sujets est-ce qu'avoir
un truc 1 est ce que vous savez
suffisamment vous motiver pour aller
chercher en anglais ou est-ce que ce
serait vraiment chouette de les avoir un
français parce que dans l'absolu je dis
ah oui mais dans mes mais dans la grande
tradition de l'altruisme efficace
j'aimerais pouvoir quantifier la
priorité jérémy doit commencer sachez
additive exactement c'est et ses pas et
c'est pas que moi c'est à dire même dans
l'assaut altruisme efficace rens on se
pose on se pose assez souvent la
question est quel quel genre de contenu
on doit traduire parce que les meet up
se font en français parce que là on
parle français par mamie top mais il ya
des trucs comme et c'est traduire il ya
des opportunités qu'on essaie de créer
et est vraiment quantifier l'impact
d'une traduction c'est très difficile à
dire quand c'est pas vraiment
quelle proportion de gens sont bilingues
parmi l'auditoire et de dire ben ok mais
de tout mais de toute façon si les gens
sur intéressé par le problème de toute
façon la majorité des gens intéressés
par le problème par l'anglais donc
qu'ils vont aller voir mes et j'arrive
pas être convaincu par cet argument donc
c'est une grande source d'incertitude
pour moi il ya que ea que les auditeurs
qui peuvent répondre parce qu'on est
tous les deux là bilingue mais mais
voilà quoi après il ya un intérêt pour
toi de faire ces vidéos je pense qui est
aussi juste s'habituer à expliquer ces
prennent possession un conseil que je
donne aux gens pour apprendre pas
forcément une chaîne youtube com est
juste expliqué régulièrement ses
problèmes dans un format qui sera
diffusé ça n'a plus la pression pour
essayer de faire des efforts
pédagogiques à d'ailleurs communs en
commun de toi tu as démarré sa haine et
son rôle bah moi j'ai vu des chaînes
décoller quoi comme celles de sociétés
notamment et du coup moi j'ai eu il ya
une grosse demande comment france galop
des mots si longtemps ouais et du coup
je me suis dit bas jusqu'à une demande
je vais lancer savoir si j'allais lancer
une chaîne en anglais avant cela et qui
n'avait pas décollé ouais du coup bah
oui ça ne marcherait mieux via le
français que et tdi n est qu on commente
a senti la commente a senti la demande
qui te dit il ya plein de gens qui sont
il ya plein de vulgarisateur populaire
en français autant rire jaune
c'est cela est juste parce que c'est pas
juste présenter du contenu accessible
c'est présenter du contenu accéder si si
si les gens vont suivre plus facilement
une chaîne française francophones qui
parle de les risques de l'ia c'est des
gens qui te serais peut-être pas les
voir au berkman
je vois mes séances jeu c'est un c'est
un bon argument
mais c'est c'est le truc c'est le truc
que donc je ne pouvais pas parler parce
que j'ai pas là j'ai pas la réponse et
je profite de mes victoires contre roger
je pense qu'il ya aussi un côté un peu
en france toute la discussion qui se
parlent et a lieu autour de l'ia jeudi
c'est notamment par rapport à tous les
livres dits on a envoyé qu'aliment il
est pas très projeter vers le futur va
dire ça comme ça
oui ou alors ce ou alors celles qui sont
projetés par le futur sur le futur son
livre comme par exemple le mythe de la
singularité et en plus ça n'aide pas que
est-ce que son prénom commence par un l
et du coup il ya besoin aussi je pense
moi dans une autre forme de
communication autour de l'iran comme
audi pré curé je suis pas le seul à en
parler aussi tu attends sk alors je
connais d'autres chaînes qui parle dire
aux français qu'ils ont tendance à être
plus technique c'est à dire ça va être
des gens qui vont dire apprenez le
machine learning les bases mathématiques
des réseaux de neurones
comment codé avec ten sur flo qui vont
baba basse et des chaînes des chaînes
plus techniques les jeux et les chaînes
à part la tienne
et je j'en ai pas vu beaucoup web et je
sens que ça va passer de passer à 20
pour le flou qui raconte les trucs des
anglophones mais non je veux juste dire
demain point de vue t2 - points de vue
et peut-être celle m'étais pas fou donc
si sa fédération
moi je joue bien je veux bien arrivé et
pierre moi de sentir ça et comme ça on
sera foot où on ne sera pas fou tous les
deux voilà et oui je pense là c'est un
cas où 2 est beaucoup plus récurrents
qu'on s'y abattent alors dans la grande
tradition de l'élite rythme efficace on
va dire que les que c'est un problème
négligé et que les premières personnes
qui se trouvent attaquer le problème
sont celles qui vont avoir probablement
le plus d'impact et voilà c'était le
truc que je pensais c'est le jour j
c'est à peu près ça prime est pas la
première personne que j'ai c'est de
convaincre de lancer sa chaîne youtube
j'ai parcouru des succès mais
globalement a eu pas mal de succès par
exemple alexandre tecno pro gay
je je je vois je vois alors poussé
directement mais en tout cas je finance
quoi il faudra aller lui demander
il ya eu pas mal de d'altruiste efficace
aussi bon jeu toujours pas vu leurs
vidéos mais j'avais plus régulièrement
raymond plus ou moins dit oui mais
j'attends corps et vie dure je pense
qu'il faut que tu les invite dans un jeu
plus pense qu'il faut que tu les invite
d'un probablement et que et qu' il se
met tout seul dans la situation où ils
s'engagent à mort dans le fait qu'ils
vont faire des vidéos est comme ça ils
vont pas pouvoir éviter de le faire
25 sorties quelques quelques futurs
guest sur moi je dis ça marche puisque
du coup est ce que tu pourrais peut-être
conclure doucement ouais ouais ouais
quel message kate aime la couleur au
vieux le viewer retiennent de cette
discussion
alors mes messages clés je dirais la
première vertu et la curiosité c'est
c'est c'est que s'il n'y a qu'une ici
ici a qu'une chose à retenir du de cette
diffusion c'est que si vous sentez qu'on
a parlé de 2,2 sujet compliqué c'est
très possible qu'il le soit et que la
meilleure façon de 2 2 2 si vous êtes
intéressé e voilà ce que je voulais dire
c'est pardon hop je recommence le truc
clé le message clé ce serait
on a parlé de sujets compliqués c'est
possible que vous soyez intéressé et que
c'est pas une fatalité que vous vous
avez l'impression que ouhlala j'ai pas
tout compris je vais essayer de de
réécouter les trois heures j'en doute
quand même mais dans l'absolu
l'important c'est la curiosité c'est de
dire le chemin vers la connaissance et
la vérité et les prédictions qui se
réalise et le et les plans qui marche
c'est de connaître le monde
ces deux c'est d'avoir une bonne carte
du monde dans laquelle vous pouvez
naviguer
donc si ça si cette conversation vous
intéresser le premier truc c'est rester
curieux
si vous êtes intéressé par un truc
n'hésitez pas à chercher d'informations
n'hésitez pas à poser des questions il
ya plein de gens qui seront ravi de
poser des questions il ya pas mal de
gens sur internet qui adore répondre aux
questions et et d'étaler leur culture
comme ils et elles leurs confitures et
et on vit on est en 2019 internet
existent nous avons les moyens
d'apprendre de découvrir des trucs on a
même les moyens de trouver des trouver
les endroits qui permettront de trouver
les endroits où trouver les endroits où
apprendre donc la curiosité c'est le
premier pas voilà c'est excellent moi je
puisse quoi largement
est-ce que j'ai pas devenir le deuxième
point c'est l'intelligence artificielle
problèmes intéressants
voilà ça c'est fait
il dit qu est ce que tu vas finir avec
des recommandations de vidéos podcasts
kivu personnes à suivre
[Musique]
alors bon les premiers trucs je vais les
donner en anglais mais après je vais
embrayé sur des trucs en français que je
connais donc en anglais
la chaîne de roberte maïs sur sur qui
explique beaucoup mieux que moi mais en
anglais les les histoires d'alignement
daisy à deux problèmes même les
problèmes un peu technique il est
vulgaris très bien le les jeux on a
beaucoup de parler d'eux les one mais la
version un peu organisés du machin c'est
un livre qui s'appelle rationality
highlights the bees encore une fois
c'est un pavé et c'est en anglais mais
si vous êtes bilingue c'est ça ce lit ça
c'est très bien c'est juste long mais ça
se lit et en français en france air
france air france est bon mais on a
mentionné intelligence
alors là il soit 15,02 max terremark je
sais pas comment il a été traduit dans
les vies 3.0 pas sûr ouais possiblement
et d'autre d'autres conseils sam
ça me fait mal de ne pas trouver de
référence immédiatement ça me fait mal
ce qui ce qui a donc je recommande la
conférence de monsieur fille sur la
super intelligence ouais si vous n'avez
pas envie de lire le bouquin super
intelligent c'est bostrom m'a suffi on a
fait un excellent résumé il est très
bien j'ai beaucoup aimé et bien sûr bas
sur le côté non y'a encore que bâle le
site de altruisme efficace france qui a
de plus en plus de contenu
chaque mois chaque ses dépend à quelle
vitesse on avance mais le le site le
site de l'association altruisme efficace
français est une excellente porte
d'entrée
voilà l'adhésion est gratuite vous
pouvez nous contacter on est extrêmement
enclins à répondre aux questions
typiquement le genre de c c'est le genre
de la maison
vous allez ils sont plus réactifs que
moi ces questions un peu pointu mais on
aime les questions pointues et et oui et
oui rien qui me vient en tête
immédiatement mais j'imagine que dans
une heure je penserai à des trucs donc
au pire d'ici à ce que tu sortes la
vidéo je posterai des trucs à la suite
sera peut-être d'autres haut dir dans
les descriptions des commentaires ceux
qui sont intéressés c'est le cas merci
beaucoup jérémy c'était vraiment super
très intéressant on attend ta chaîne
youtube avec des dizaines et des
centaines de millions d'abonnés du
moment et en tous cas pour vous qu
écouter à vous dis merci d'avoir écouté
et à bientôt
probablement non merci